hi welcome to an ALT shift X live stream
to talk about the brand new house of the
Dragon season 2 teaser trailer we've had
our first glimpses of the next season
and to discuss it I have a very special
guest please welcome glidus a glimpse of
glidus a little glimpse of glidus glidus
is a Game of Thrones YouTuber who has
done a bunch excuse me the term is
youtubeist youtubeist Dragon man about
town uh who has made a bunch of videos
about House of the dragon and Game of
Thrones and I believe you have a house
of the Dragon episode 10 video coming
out very soon very soon if it doesn't
come out it's YouTube's fault yeah we we
blame YouTube for any uh uh delays or
errors that we my to last night that was
YouTube's fault Susan yeah that's
correct um we've known each other for a
long time but we've never actually done
anything together this is the first time
we've live streamed together I've heard
that you have live streamed extensively
with my
disreputable Nemesis Al schwift X your
scarless counterpart but I'll forgive
you for that and I'm happy to be here to
talk about Hot D me too how exciting to
receive new content after all this time
to be reminded that the show exists yeah
I I watched this trailer and I rewatched
some of season 1 and I I remembered how
much I like this show I I sort of forgot
what it was like to enjoy a Game of
Thrones West Ros TV show because that's
just the thing because most people
haven't experienced this show in over a
year was it's been I've been thinking
about it ever since yeah you've been
deep in the trenches of hot day for a
long time now so I'm so glad to have
your expert dragon eye no on this
trailer is that what I'm supposed to be
so we're going to go through the trailer
uh pretty much shot by shot and talk
about what we're excited by what some of
the details might mean who is this
person and this Dragon what's what's
going on we're going to get into it and
we're going to answer any questions that
you guys have uh I think we'll mostly
answer super chats towards the end of
the live stream but we'll answer some
throughout the live stream as well and
uh with spoilers we're going to we're
not going to do any major plot spoilers
we're not going to tell you anything
super important uh that's going to
happen next season but we will do some
like basic information about some of the
new characters and some of the some of
the general stuff that might be going on
without spoiling anything important not
going to ruin the show for you that's
right um
so what's first in this trailer what
happens glidus um well narration firstly
what's a good trailer without narration
um we've got Auto telling us um
basically coping as to what happened at
the end of season one um trying to
explain away the actions of um himself
Allison rir and aan probably foremostly
yeah I love the um the passive grammar
of errors were made as opposed to have
died yeah it's such political language
instead of admitting no I auto made some
mistakes um when that whole fcal race
happened between Allison and Otto to
take control of Prince aegon so that
they could make him King and all the all
the um embarrassing um violence that
followed um it's been basically a
disaster but uh and one of the
consequences of that was the death of
re's son Luke at the hands of vagar and
amond at Storm's end so Luke's mother
rero is here looking over shipbreaker
Bay looking at storms end I've seen some
some people speculating that rer might
be here like searching for the body of
her son Luke I could see that
um CU I think I think there is in the
books there's that talk about how the
body was never found yeah the body was
never found and some people claim that
Luke actually miraculously survived
falling from his Dragon into the water
and then lived out the rest of his days
as a simple-minded farm boy or something
doesn't the book say that yeah there
there is mention of that um I I'm more
inclined to believe that the squishes
took him
yes yeah in the books um there are these
lovecraftian uh creatures who come from
the Sea called squishes and um there are
some like semi-reliable reports that
they like really exist and might like
take people down Into the Depths and
stuff but um yeah this was Luke on arax
who got killed by Vega at the end of
last season sge and we also saw re's
like reaction to the death of her son
cuz throughout episode 10 reier was
trying to as um as Ry says um with all
of these counselors telling her to
plunge the realm into war reneer is the
only one who's practiced restraint yes
and aund kills that restraint here and
so this is the last shot of season 1
we're ready for Rene's Dragon to awaken
and for uh Fire and Blood to engulf the
realm yeah hooray
yeah so so so like I it was sort of a
cliffhanger at the end of last season
wasn't it because we we don't know H how
rier is going to react to this traumatic
death of her son um her middle son the
son who was not so confident cuz like
her eldest Jace is so sort of like
confident and educated and um has a lot
of strength and confidence to him but
Luke had all that doubt he's definitely
favorite coded as you can see throughout
like the last he absolutely is in
episode 8 and 10 like he he is coddled
he is like absolutely Rene's like baby
boy um and like in in the scene where
she farewells them when he rides off to
Storm's end yeah like he's such a little
baby boy and Renea um you know treats
him as such and so you know it's
basically the death of
whatever peace and happiness still
resided in this woman after losing her
her daughter and her father on the same
day and her crown yeah and also her
unborn baby via who died like R has lost
so much so suddenly um so there's going
to be so much emotion I mean guilt is
going to be part of it for pushing Luke
into this situation and anger I um to
entertain a tangent for a little bit
which you might come to find is
something I do rather regularly oh
really um I was wondering if because
jeris is the one who suggest just
sending himself and Luke to treat with
the great Lords of Westeros he might
jeris Jer he might blame himself for in
some way for what happened to Luke yeah
that's an interesting idea I mean Jace
um I find quite an interesting character
um there's a few layers to him because
we've seen him sort of wanting to be
this dutiful son I I mean when he was
young he was like um upset about the
bastard thing wasn't he like he he was
asking his mother rer am I a bastard cuz
of course he's the son of how and strong
not the son of Lor he's like questioning
his identity how that like makes him
work in the world yeah a bit like Jon
Snow and his bastardy so he's got a lot
of like Pathos and and sort of fear in
him but we see as he gets older he he
becomes quite quite confident and for it
doesn't matter what people think is is
what he's saying here to Luke yeah and
and I think I speculated in a video that
he might see donon as a bit of a role
model um in that sort of defiant
attitude and there's that scene in
episode 10 where Damon takes uh Jace to
intimidate the King's Guard and he's
like showing Jace that hey fear is how
we get people to do what we want yeah so
it's like what kind of person is Jace
going to be in this season so you know
coupled with the reaction of his
brother's death at the hands of a and
this like new found vengeful
fearsome character what is Jay's
reaction going be I'm really excited to
see how they depict this in season two
absolutely when he's at um the eie and
Winterfell yeah cuz remember of course
reer sent Jace North on his Dragon to go
and uh convince the The Veil The aand of
the veil and the Starks of the north to
support rier in this war against aegon
and Allison um so yeah I mean is he
going to you know he's trying to be a
diplomat but he might be really angry at
the death of the news of his brother so
he was made to swear that he wouldn't
get up to any silly business but uh he's
in the mood if there's one lesson from
Hot D it's that silly business is an
inevitability you can't control when the
silly business happens it strikes when
you least expect um so yeah uh so rira
is reacting to oh right the trailer the
trailer so rer is reacting to the death
of her Sun Luke um and I I love that it
shows her like standing here facing
storms in we've never seen storms end
from this angle yeah yeah I love I love
that hot D is showing us more of the
sort of GE and landmarks that we never
got to see in in episode five we saw
runstone again it it appeared in one
episode of Game of Thrones and they
reused the design it was really it was
really cool that they did that yeah yeah
again I I have been impressed by hot D's
um willingness to like stay like respect
the the Canon of both the Game of
Thrones books and The Game of Thrones TV
show which is not an easy thing to
reconcile sometimes but also to sort of
um iterate and and and from that to make
itself its own thing Theon Throne like
the Iron Throne yeah yeah the compromise
between the Game of Thrones and Ice and
Fire iron Thrones yeah it keeps what is
Iconic about the Game of Thrones TV show
but it adds stuff to make it better and
it's completely believable that over
time it would become what we see in Game
of Thrones um I don't know Haren Hall is
a bit small yeah it's true um but yeah
mostly they' made great compromises yeah
we also see some really cool shots of
Kings Landing in this trailer yeah
different angles we've never seen before
yeah I'm really curious what they'll do
if they show costly Rock like are they
going to show us the cool big book cast
rock or the small lame show Castle Rock
God I hope not anyway High Garden as
well how disappointing yeah right um so
I mean so rer is standing here outside
Storm's end she must have flown here on
a dragon
Cyrax which means like she must be
thinking how about I burn storm right
how about I go in here and hold Boris
barathan accountable for not stopping
this yeah um cuz this is yeah the Lord
boros here allowed the murder of her son
to happen as far as she knows yeah um
why not kill boros and install her own
loyalists take over the stormlands right
now like that that's got to be one of
the things going through Rainier's head
right now um but it seems you know grief
and sadness is most of what's going on
for boing music plays uhoh
uhoh and then we see King are we going
to call him king or are we going to call
him the usurper he's King go he's King
whatever the history books call him a
king we'll call him a king has the
conqueror's crown and the conqueror's
name and The conqueror's Sword and the
conqueror's throne and the conqueror's
set of genitals he sure
does um so what kind of King is aegon II
going to be do you think one whose Crown
is too big for his head and I think that
that's an intentional um costuming
metaphor yeah it does look heavy on his
brow does doesn't it that that Crown
yeah I I I actually really like what
they've done with he's he's not entirely
capable of um living up to aegon the
conqueror's
Legacy yeah yeah it but he but he wants
to yeah as we saw in episode 9 when he
was crowned and you know he for the
first time experienced the agulation of
anyone um when you know 10,000 commoners
cheered him it's like yeah we got a new
king [__] here um and uh he you could
see on his face he was so excited well
it was more relief it was he was feeling
love for the first time it's crazy yeah
that I mean that's what he asks Allison
on the way to his coronation is do you
love me and Allison replies you imbecile
you're an idiot um so so when I love
that line so much yeah me too episode 9
is sometimes a bit hard to handle but
it's got some really great bits as well
yeah yeah so so I I I mean my feeling at
least from this is you know I I feel
like there's a question here like is it
possible that aegon II this this
monstrous person um who you know puts
his own children into a fighting pit and
who rapes servants and who is a really
really horrible person is it possible
that he might be a little bit less
terrible is it possible that he could
actually make some half decent decisions
now that he's been crowned could he live
up to this responsibility or will he
just be terrible I'll be really
interested to see what they do with him
excited to see how he reacts to this
change in circumstances yeah because he
he rejected the crown he really didn't
want this yeah and now that he's you
know well let's see what we can do with
it now that we're here and he laughed at
the idea that his father viseris uh
would have actually wanted him to be the
king so he he he doesn't really believe
in his own legitimacy like like he like
in the books especially it acknowledges
that no Aon thinks reain is the right
they come to crown him and he's like
hang on a moment I thought it was my
sister's turn that's one of the
interesting things about the books is
that the books emphasize that it was
Kristen Cole Who convinced aegon that he
should take the throne and he should
take it because riro will kill aegon if
he doesn't take it I think in some sense
that's a hold over from when George was
inventing the dance of dragons like in
his head it was this story of brother
fights brother in Eric and Eric Carill
and Kristen Cole the treacherous King's
Guard who you know betrayed his King's
orders and crowned you know he was Bes
smurged by The Princess and so he
decided to Crown yeah it like it became
a lot less it became more involved with
other people as the story evolved in
George's head is what I'm getting at
yeah yeah in like the early mentions of
the dance of the dragons in the main
Game of Thrones books it largely is a
story about Kristen Cole and about
Kristen Cole's uh breaking his King's
Guard principles by getting involved in
politics and the reason for that is
because it relates to how characters in
those stories are currently dealing with
their own King's SC vows yeah so like
Aris oart with Ariana and the dornish
plot and Jamie with all of his misdeeds
it's like the purpose of Kristen in the
main series is to meditate on um what
George always bloody meditates on which
is about like when should we when do we
compromise our duty to the greater good
and our principles for our own personal
desires and for our own loyalties and
like like that's sort of what the dance
of the Dragons kind of was is about
Kristen in that situation but of course
um George as he does gardened and and
and grew the story into something much
bigger and that's how we got hot D
yep so Aon I love aon's outfit here by
the way yeah he passes the drip check
once more like one of the things about
the Game of Thrones especially the later
Seasons at the TV show is that everyone
just wore dark colored nondescript
leather outfits cool and edgy whereas
the books talk about all of the fancy
clothes and the jewelry and the color
and the crowns and all of the drip that
the rulers had it looked like a party
yeah and and it's and it's about the you
know social status hierarchy you look at
aegon here and it's like okay this
person this person is important he's a
king so I'm really glad that they they
capture some of that look at his Swagger
too look at him go well well he's kind
of like like he's got a little bit of a
defense like his head is tilted down a
bit and he's sort of
side eyeing everything like he looks not
entirely sure of himself to me like he
looks a little bit solid he looks a bit
hung over actually he's probably hung
over um and then we see Damon Targaryen
the RO Prince um he's taking his helmet
that we saw in episode one of House of
the Dragon yeah we uh previously saw
Damon uh bashing someone in the face
with this helmet on the step stones
Friday we it in that episode as well um
and we've also seen
dayon wearing this helmet at the
tournament this this helmet is
apparently made of Valyrian steel which
is ridiculous actually is it the same
helmet this one has wings maybe he takes
them off when you know it's just a
display for the Tony is it is it
possible that the wings break off at
some point like on the stepstone or
maybe they break off on this guy
skull oh man you would not well if it's
breaking off Valyrian steel yeah
Valyrian steel would not break off very
easily he's got a skull of Valyrian
steel a skull of Valyrian steel yeah
this guy's hardcore oh my gosh um yeah
well the point is that Damon is ready
for
war yep and check out his armor too cuz
he's been wanting a war since episode
one of season one and now his wife is
finally like yeah all right War it is
yeah cuz that was the conflict in
episode 10 wasn't it that like rier was
trying to find a peaceful solution
trying to like connect with her old
friend Allison to avert this war partly
because of the responsibility of the
prophecy that viseris told her about
where you know they need to unite
Westeros against the White Walkers that
are going to come one day whereas
Damon's like don't worry Arya Stark will
take care of it exactly um and so let's
just do the war anyway yeah he pays
absolutely no heed to viseris portance
and dreams he says that viseris was a
slave to these things and he doesn't
care for any that but I think part of
why Damon was so dismissive is because
he didn't get included oh he was Mega
upset yeah yeah like maybe if AAS had
shown Damon more trust maybe donon would
have been a little bit more responsible
not to spoil my dire tribe from my video
which is coming out hopefully later
today um Damon learns in that moment
when riro posts leaks about aegon's
prophecy he learns that viseris never
trusted him he was never a viseris air
in his head he was only you know just
that guy on the periphery yeah at least
that's how it feels to Damon yeah so
what does that mean for him in season
two I mean is he just going to be more
of a loose unit if he doesn't get that
trust that he wanted I mean you know I
mean it it makes the relationship with
reir more important doesn't it like you
know if if Damon isn't acting as much
out of loyalty to viseris then his
relationship and loyalty to reer is
going to be even more important but of
course that was like so under thre in
episode 10 um when Damon choked Rainier
after finding out that he was not
included um didn't get invited to the
party got mad about
it so you know Damon is one of Reiner's
most important allies not to mention her
husband um but he attacks her and he is
dangerous and unreliable so like this
this relationship is
incredibly um fraught and important
that's right this is an image that it's
not included in the teaser but it is
like a promotional image for season two
yeah there are some new uh promotional
shots that came out that are quite nice
I really like how Damon's armor looks it
looks so cool it's probably impractical
in some Niche way that I'm too stupid to
comprehend but it looks so cool well
he's sitting he's sitting for a meal
wearing gauntlets how's he going to
how's he going to cut his meat with
those gauntlets he's got people for
that yeah yeah but we got some really
nice shots in here that uh we will talk
about as we go on oh man I haven't seen
this one yet that's so cool amond is
just unbelievably cool he's so cool he
looks like he's really uh growing and uh
becoming more confident you know and
we'll discuss that as we move on with
the trailer which we are currently 10
seconds
into we see a camp with a targaryan
banner looks like armies are on the move
a Allison says the war war will be
fought many will die and the Victor will
Ascend the throne so it seems as though
peace is an impossibility and war is
inevitable yeah in episode 9 Allison was
also clamoring for peace she was going
on about how we need to you know
negotiate a way for rira to not declare
war on us you know have her give her
what she needs so that she can get away
and then we'll leave her alone
forever but that appears to be
the Lost resolution and now war is the
only way through partly because of you
know um Otto and Damon and some of those
more saber rattling Lords and they all
seem to uh relish the opportunity for
War I mean it's like rise was saying in
like episode one about how like it's
been a long period of peace and there
are all these like young Knights who
want prove themselves and win glory and
and they've forgotten the horrible
Bloodshed of war that characterized
jeris the old King's early Reign yeah I
wonder who sent aund to storms and like
whose decision was it to send aund
specifically to Storm's end yeah because
that is sort of a catalyst for violence
no matter which way you you uh you spin
it I mean only in the case where Luke
shows up I guess but if Jace had been
there something could have happened as
well yeah yeah I wonder if he just did
it of his own accord you know well he
seemed to you know have the Diplomatic
power to betro himself to one of boris's
daughters well he he believed that he
did yeah um and one of the other
interesting we shall see if that gets
followed up on yes we also get to see
Amon looking at the iron throne hungrily
in this trailer cuz Amon made that
interesting comment in episode 9 about
um how he considers himself next in next
in line for the throne which is not true
um because King aegon II has
children does he have three children in
the show have we seen all of them yes we
have uh well well no this is just a
placeholder AI image of meor but we have
seen uh agon and Helena's uh twins Jara
and jeris and they do also have at least
according to the family tree thing in
the intro they do have three children
that's right that's right they do have
three children so and all of these three
children come before amond in line for
the throne so you know Amon has some uh
uh uh overinflated ideas of his own um
importance he wants the throne um
despite the fact that Aon and his
children are ahead of him so it'll be
interesting to see how that plays
out uh we see so all right so we see all
these armies on the Move we see a high
tower
Army and they look very um Ready for War
professional organized
uniform it's a rich look at all that
plate yeah that doesn't come cheap and
we've got the green flamed high tower
which as we learned in episode five is
you know their symbol of War yeah true
because I think I think normally armies
are also a symbol of War so a bit very
very subtle but it's there yeah I yeah
cuz the high tower sigil is normally
depicted with just like a yellow or
orange flame but the green flame yeah
maybe for their soldiers specifically
they have the green flame for war so
that's cool and of course the high
towers are like lowy one of the most
fascinating houses in West because
they're so old they're so rich they run
the biggest city of Oldtown and like in
the current main story The High Towers
don't do much yet they're barely even
mentioned they're barely mentioned in
the main series but like there's all
these little hints about how the lord
it's Leighton High Tower um he's one of
George's little fantasy characters that
he likes hinting at all the spooky stuff
going on
with yeah cuz leighton's into magic um
and he's up there with his crazy
daughter malora the Mad maid and they're
doing magic together and they've been up
there for a decade and no one knows
what's going on it's very exciting and
now Sam's there and God I want to read
the next Sam chapter and euron is
knocking on their door so yeah House
hotel is is cool it's so great being
able to see them from different
historical periods uh so we see that an
army here A bunch of soldiers with the
rosby mentioned Get Hype yeah this
Shield here with the red stripes is
house rosby uh and this is with the lamb
is House stokeworth of stokeworth is the
houses that are both located very close
to King's Landing in the crown lands
yeah these are both fairly minor um
houses uh but they are right outside
King's Landing so anyone who wants to
have control of King's Landing is going
to talk to these people and so as of
season 1 we don't know if rosby and
stokeworth are siding with uh rira or
with Aon we know that rira has control
over most of the rest of the crownlands
or at least the north side she has
support from the masses the darklands
the uh bar Emmons uh another one yeah
yeah a bunch of the crown Landers are
siding with riera last we heard yeah um
so maybe stokeworth and rosby will as
well maybe they won't maybe their
proximity to the greens controlled Kings
Landing will sway them towards them
though yeah yeah so it looks it it looks
as though with all these armies and
stuff this will be one of the contested
areas is the crown lands around King's
Landing uh uh fans of house rosby will
of course know gues rosby who's the Lord
of rosby during the main series who is
most noted for
his yeah that's sorry everyone that's
one of the best quotes from G rosby
that's from Dance with Dragons chapter
he's on cersei's ineffectual small
Council and he's just sort of useless
lip what Banners are back there in the
background is that the greens Banner a
golden dragon on a Green Field uh yeah I
suppose it must be it could be um cuz
yeah like the one of the problems with
this war is that both sides are on house
tug area
um which makes it difficult to tell
who's on whose side so the greens which
that really does look like the greens
Banner yeah yeah the the targaryan
dragon and Yellow on green so that so
that is aegon um Aon and Allison side we
solve the mystery so this suggests that
stokeworth and rosby have joined aegon
which makes sense yeah it would make
sense either way really I mean it's
interesting that these shields are all
bloody that's a lot of blood on these
shields
actually how how many people are they
bashing with their Shields my God so um
so yeah it looks like war is happening
in the crown lands Get Hype Get Hype oh
and oh and while we're talking about the
stoew worths um the stoew worths are
involved in the main series through
lless
stokeworth so you'll remember that Braun
uh is does he marry or is he just
engaged to Mar they're betrothed they
never actually marry yeah um and so in
the books there's a bit more of a
plotline about the stoew worths how uh
lady Tander stokeworth worth ls's mother
um there's this whole thing where like
Cersei uses Bron no well Bron's working
for Tyrion I can't even remember exactly
what goes down but like Brun gets Lord
stokeworth killed so that Brun can take
over stokeworth yeah um it's a whole
thing and Cersei thinks this is good for
Cersei but it turns out to not be good
for Cersei which is a bit of a recurring
theme yeah you've described most of a
face for
Crows uh so yeah it's cool to see the
stokeworth and the rosb who's next
that's Otto hi Tower he's the hand of
the king and the brother of Sir uh Lord
Hobert high tower accurate and Lord of
Oldtown that's a queen Allison high
tower Queen Mother Allison high tower
important distinction yeah I uh adore uh
Olivia Cook's expression here she's got
so many great faces yeah she's she she's
just brilliant she's fantastic and I I
love like the sense of just cynicism
that is right there that's going viral
on Twitter as we speak that's fantastic
CU like she was so fresh-faced and so
well-intentioned like a you know Prim
proper herione Granger when she was
younger played by Emily KY and Emily KY
has some great snarky faces as well she
does but I mean that just that you know
character change as she's become
hardened and as she's become sort of
corrupted by people like Laris and
Kristen and and her father Otto she is
so just cynical now it makes me wonder
like how a young Cersei Lannister would
have looked and behaved before she
became so Jaded by Robert baratheon's
mistreatment of her I I would love to
like read a Nolla about the young
Lannisters about like young C young
Jamie young Tyrion and with like their
uncles garion and Tig around and their
[__] Dad yeah and like taiwan's
relationship with his dad titos I I've
always felt that the Lannisters are the
best characters in a song of ice and
fire they're just so messed up and so
charismatic and so awful and so great I
love
it boats we love us some boats uh
Kristen Cole has had a bit of a haircut
he now actually looks like he's aged and
you know what else he has the necklace
of Hands by the looks of it is that the
necklace of hands yeah that's a necklace
of hands so you'll remember that uh a
similar hand necklace was used by Tyrion
Lannister to murder sheay in Game of
Thrones uh season 4 I've never seen Game
of Thrones so I've heard it's
good yeah see that see that necklace of
hands well I did actually no that's
actually that's a different necklace
that's not the necklace of hands is that
the chain of gold yeah that's just a
chain of gold um but you can trust me
when I say that there is a just trust me
bro Source I made it up no yeah there is
this necklace of hands that represents
being hand of the king so that is what
is suggested by that necklace uh Kristen
of course has undergone um quite a
dramatic Journey from a seemingly Noble
White Knight into a
murderer uh an angry murderer who's
really uh pissed off that reera sort of
messed him around by having sex with him
and then rejecting him and breaking his
King's Guard Oaths and now he is
Allison's foremost attack dog and it
looks like Allison is using him to full
effect we see Kristen beheading someone
here who is that uh we can speculate uh
we but not without spoiling I think I
think I think we can have a idea of who
it is we might do a brief spoiler corner
at the end of this live stream to talk
about some of that stuff but um yeah it
looks like Kristen is out killing uh Aon
and Allison's
enemies uh I love that yeah we've got
the spinny balls I love love the council
balls they are cool little visual motifs
it's good to see that they'll be
continued to be utilized throughout the
show instead of just you know that one
thing in season one I I just I want to
see all the creative ways that balls are
used in hot day cuz I I thought it was
cool how uh Lyman beesy was killed by
Kristen Cole by bashing his head into
one of these Stone Council balls I liked
the
execution like the method I didn't
really care for the uh tone
like that that scene has issues that
yeah we shall not discuss at this moment
yeah um I I I've been saying all season
that I am waiting to see one of those
Council balls roll into a puddle of
blood on the table Yeah like that's got
to happen at some point leaving a trail
of blood behind it as it rolls
maybe uh but yeah aegon is on the throne
he he doesn't look like he wants to be
there or should be there he's looking a
bit scary and Evil um what kinds of
decisions is he going to make as the
most powerful man in Westeros this this
awful person he's going to ban
beats and this is directly contrasted
with reneir in her crown on her doesn't
really look like a throne it's a seat
it's a chair but she's looking really
sort of optimistic it's a funny face God
those are the coolest shoulder pads I
have ever seen I've got some just like
them yeah no she's got some great drip
going on here I like a necklace as well
I wonder if there's any significance to
that necklace cuz I remember Damon gives
reer a Valyrian steel necklace in season
one but yeah it's different isn't it you
know what that looks a bit like go on
that looks a bit like the KN King's
little jewelry who what Mr first name
Knight second name King see see how it's
a down arrow I guess it's a it's
pointing down and that's pointing down I
suppose it's one of the four directions
it could have been going is rira the
night King no we talked about this it's
a he well he does have blue eyes doesn't
he yeah he's always had blue eyes
actually no he hasn't he's the one
character
who's I know George has written a few
characters whose eye cols change isn't
that alone from season 8 I've always had
blue eyes at last half yeah we know too
much about this series I think we've
thought about this for too long and of
course I I really like the crown
symbolism in Hot D um because in the
books there's lots of attention given to
to the specific crowns and their
symbolism because you know aegon is
wearing the crown of aegon the first
aegon the Conqueror who took over
Westeros for the tarians it's a crown
made of Valyrian steel or iron depending
on who you ask um but it's it it sort it
represents a more sort of warlike
conquering um Vibe whereas and it's in
it's embossed with embossed it's in
great it's got rubies in it to signify
like targaryan specific power right and
blood yeah whereas as you say as you
were about to say
uh so whereas reier is wearing her
father vas's Crown which was previously
worn by King jeris his grandfather uh
and that represents more peace and unity
you can see that it's got the Tully uh
sigil there and all the different great
houses sigils and so it represents a
more sort of like unified representative
let's all work together Seven Kingdoms
type Vibe very different to the warlike
angry bloody Aon Crown Aon the Conqueror
conquered the Seven Kingdoms and Jaris
the conciliator you know unified he kept
them together it so it's just emblematic
of the characteristics of both of their
Reigns yeah so what will win out peace
or War H Allison blows out a flame like
birthday like she wants to Snuff out
rira's flame
perhaps um yeah it's a candle uh HBO
original series returns I'm not sure if
TV networks know what them know what the
word original
means we made this cuz cuz this is a
adaptation of a book that's based on
another book that's based on the English
Anarchy that happened 600 this is a 600y
old story The Anarchy happened more than
600 years ago when was it is the late
12th century or early what was it the
early 12th century yeah so they're about
800 years late from originality I I I
feel but um nonetheless now this is an
interesting that you wanted to talk
about yeah we did some uh chin
comparison on the internet to figure
this out um I'm not 100% sure who this
character is but based on chin math and
based on uh speculation on the internet
I think this is actor Clinton Liberty
playing the
character Adam of H it's Adam isn't it
not Alan I believe so yes um and so
we'll give you some mild sort of
background information on this character
no big spoiler but one of the sort of
important things about this character is
that this is said to be a basted son of
Lor
valion so Lor valion you'll remember is
the son of corus valion and Lor was
married to reira and Lor was the
supposed father of Jace Luke and Joff
even though those children were actually
fathered by harn and Lor is gay and he
was in a relationship with Joff free and
then in a relationship with KL and then
rer faked Lor's death and Lor went East
um so that everyone thinks that Lor is
dead but he's actually alive in the East
which is a change from the books the
story is so simple right um and so and
so then you know this character Adam's
going to turn up um and say hey I am a
bastard son of Lor and no one's going to
believe him it would be a bit odd if
this homosexual man had a bunch of Bast
I mean possible possible I suppose but
it would it surprises some people he he
was a fan of the sperm banks it
surprises some people so we uh we will
find out more about this character and
his role and we see this character
looking up at a dragon and that dragon
is you say they probably sea smoke yeah
I I think it's definitely sea smoke you
say it's probably sea smoke will agree
to disagree well to me one blurry lizard
looks much like the other but I'll Trust
your I'll Trust your Eagle Eye um no
let's definitely see smoke you can tell
from the
pixels so there's a bunch of dragons in
this story and one of the things that
was discussed uh in the previous season
was that the blacks which is rira's side
has a bunch more dragons than the greens
which is aon's side uh cuz on Dragon
Stone there's a bunch of uh dragons that
don't currently have Riders and one of
the things the blacks want to do is get
riders for these free dragons um so we
saw Damon come and say hello to veror hi
who was once uh the dragon of King jares
and Silverwing his Queen um all these
free dragons that they're going to want
to find riters for is one of the things
that's going on so you know with such
alluring names as cannibal cannibal who
wants to ride the cannibal what could
possibly go wrong I mean I guess you'd
feel safer with a cannibal Dragon
because it doesn't eat humans it eats
dragons um I think it'll eat whatever
mate so we see what yeah appears to SE
smoke but of course yeah I mean there's
a lot of interesting questions about sea
smoke aren't there because you know if
in the TV show Lor is still alive will
sees smoke bond with a new Rider if sees
smoke is still bonded to Lor is it
possible that sea smoke will want to
find Lor you know like cuz Lor really
loved sea smoke and we saw them we saw
him riding sea smoke and going yeeha and
so um so it would uh it would be a bit
it would be interesting yeah I contend
that like every piece of evidence we
have points towards dragons with living
riters being unable to bond with other
humans yeah so so I think one thing that
people have speculated is that you know
if seasmoke does bond with a new writer
that would suggest that dead which could
be like a really beautiful tragic moment
for R going like oh like I went to all
this effort to try and free Lor from
this political mess uh but he's just
gone and died
um I think that could be a really great
moment yeah Ryan if you're listening
you're allowed to steal that yeah you
can have that one for free Ryan yeah
when I'm sure I would have thought of it
when's Ryan going to come on the show
huh yeah huh huh Ryan come on Ryan what
are you afraid of we'll ask you nice
questions too busy on your podcast about
movie
props there are there are a lot of good
props in this actually the love for the
helmet you this staff actually that
Adam's got yeah for a moment it it
reminded me of the Dragon Keepers and
staff so I wonder if we might speculate
that he wants a little dragon stick so
that he can use it to prod dragons with
just like the pro Dragon Keepers do a
keen observation yes well I know a stick
when I see
one can't tell a
dragon so we see this Army marching uh
and those with Keen eyes might notice
that this is in fact a darkland or at
least has some darklands in it darklands
of duskendale is another minor house in
the
crownlands um because if we Zoom right
on in uh we can see right is the
darkland sigil trust
me uh I I [__] you not verified facts I
can pull up the darkland sigil and the
darklands are extinct by the time of um
of the main Series yeah the dark did a
bit of an oopsy by kidnapping King Aries
tarian the Mad uh which was a crime that
was not
forgiven um yeah those particular frames
you can't see it but it is the dark ones
uh their blood does survive on and of
course the most noble of characters SOS
H yes ever reliable donos and you know
Barrison seli like part of his backstory
is that he saved the Mad King from
duskendale a morally neutral thing to do
yeah George sure does love his morally
fraught uninteresting things yeah um and
yeah as as we were saying we will answer
most of the super chats um towards the
end of the live stream thank you so much
for all the super chats we appreciate
them very much and we will get to them
towards the end of the live stream and
yeah just a reminder that we're not
doing any big plot spoilers in this live
stream so don't worry about that we're
just doing some sort of background info
and some sort of non-spoilery stuff
about what's to come we're just having a
chat really we're just having a good old
Yak I love this line
there is no war so hateful to the gods
as a war between kin and no war so
bloody as a war between
dragons I I think that that is what Ryan
Condell told HBO to convince them to
Greenlight this series H CU this is what
George is all about he just loves the
drama of a war amongst family and he
loves the violence and excitement of of
a war between dragons and that's what
this is it's just the maximum amount of
and emotion that you can possi ring from
a story so that's what the dance is all
about we get to see the painted table uh
with reira so many candles planning her
War this is a funny little symbol that
she's got on the painted table isn't it
that is that the same symbol as a
necklace there I don't think it is uh
it's
similar let's pull up the
necklace no it's not yeah I don't I
don't think it's that looks like a raven
skull that that does look like the
bloody night King's thing it's it does
but that's so weird I I I assume it's a
coincidence but you know if after all
this time it turns out that the night
King actually is a character from this
era of targaryan History I'm going to
lose my mind look we know that time
travel is a thing in this series so it's
not all that far not like physical
permanent oh I'm in the past now sort of
time travel and yet they've got a very
similar taste in jewelry what does that
tell you huh it's even got like the
thing within the thing design you know
which is of course unique to this
necklace that's pretty similar it is
really similar that's very
similar oh
no no no this is more kite shaped and
and it like diverts like a quarter of
the way down whereas this one is it's
like inverted well this one has little
dangly bits on it as well the night
Kings the dangly bit around it
completely different well it also
reminds me of brienne's armor in season
8 which is a raven skull which is a
raven skull and which also looks quite a
lot like
that but of course bran is the night
King so it connect bran is the night
King and is
Rainer don't tell me that that's not
weird it's a little weird that's it's
even got like the little dangly bits
doesn't
it those dang bits oh those are like the
Raven ribs feathers legs body Ravens
don't have that many legs yeah yeah kind
of looks like ribs doesn't it yeah yeah
well yeah extremely the branches of a
weirwood
tree yeah well I can't wait to get a
closer look at some of that jewelry
later on and and yeah yeah all those
symbols also look vaguely like like this
thing um but yeah they'll be planning
their War they'll be figuring out who
are their allies who are the enemies it
might not be the night King I've decided
that is Eric Gil behind rira there yeah
and not Eric because that would make no
sense so quick Kings guard reminder
update Kings guard hour do do you want
to go through the Kings guard Corner two
in the very first scene of House of the
Dragon we see oh God I forgotten his
name the the King's Guard who was the
Lord Commander red Brian red Ryan red
Ryan red wine um who died and then
Harold wesling became the Commander
after him and he uh just stormed off in
the middle of episode 9 he just like got
up and left and we don't know where he
went so that's one of the Kings guard
and the other and three of the others
Lauren marbrand Stephan darkland and
Eric kgill with the blacks with riro on
Dragonstone Christen colon Eric Carill
uh with the greens in King's Landing
pledged to Aon and the seventh Kings
guards like there are always seven Kings
guard um we don't know if Harold wesling
is still a Kings guard so they might
have another one to fill but um this the
seventh Kings guard was never really
revealed to us in House of the Dragon
season 1 but there are two people from
the books that it could be and uh oh God
I forgotten their names uh one of
them's I I I noted it in my video and
it's escaped my mind because it's not
that important to me um but there two
folks that it could
be uh we can look that up if we so feel
if we so feel um Eric kgill and Eric K
are identical twins and they're played
by identical twins in the show Luke teda
and Elliot Willis fell Willis fell yes
that's one of them and Mar Waters no
that's
later
um rard thorn rard thorn Ricard Thorn
who is a distant relative of Alisa Thorn
from Game of
Throne the game of the throne uh thank
you this was the King's Guard corner
with
glus callus he's had an interesting few
years yeah he's been around and back his
uh his family seems to be dying off one
by one that's it seems to be basically
an indirect result of things he's done
yeah because his wife Reus keeps telling
him hey callus can we please not be so
involved in politics because it keeps
getting our family killed it seems to be
murdering our children but Kus is like
no it's really important that I have a
legacy well in the scene before this
Callis decided yeah you know what we've
gone too far and I've got nothing to
show for it we're going to retire to to
drift Mark and we're not going to but
we'll decl declare for no one and just
live out our lives and ignore this and
rainy is like that's crazy we are in to
deep now and then in the next scene kis
looks at Raina and Baylor his only um
surviving descendants and they're
standing next to Jason Luke like they're
fully entangled in Rene's family there
is no way out for the valarian except
through this war with riro yeah so Kus
kind of did the worst possible thing
which is that he he got his family
involved to the hilt and then realized
that it was a terrible idea and tried to
back out but it was too late so so like
what position does that leave him in now
like is he going to be sort of defensive
and trying to find an out for his family
or is he going to be like okay let's
just end this as quickly and brutally as
possible to just finish it or like you
know what is or how about we all just
pack up and sail back to you know like
what are the options here back to Vala
cuz remember the important fact about
Kus is that he's a great sea Voyager
he's been all over the world he's
fabulously Rich he's self-made man
self-made man very uh from his position
of nobility yes uh very arrogant and
confident they have the dragon uh well
well the tarians have the dragon rioting
blood but the valaran just have the
Valyrian blood but not Dragon riding
Valyrian blood complicated genetics uh
but he his uh children uh through his
marriage to rise have the tarian dragon
riding blood so that's how his um his
children Lor and Lena were able we
should probably pull up the bloody
family tree Lor and Lena were able to
ride dragons vagar and sea smoke um and
Lena's children with Damon can ride
dragons uh Baya has the dragon Moon
Dancer Raina does not yet have a
dragon that was your valion dragon
update
so yeah interested to see what callus
does next
yeah uh demon he's working out
he's working his uh appear his biceps
and his delts at the same time he's he's
really going for that looks like quite a
good dance
actually uh so there's a wewood tree in
the background uh we've seen a wewood
tree in King's Landing there are wewood
trees in many castles around
Westeros um some of them have been
burned or cut down at very various
points uh so this really could be a lot
of different places um to our knowledge
Dragon Stone doesn't have
one yeah or rather to our lack of
knowledge we don't know if it does it it
seems like it shouldn't but it might I
guess well well Dragon King Landing does
doesn't does melisandra burn a weirwood
at Dragon Stone in book two oh in the
books jeez cuz she burns the statues of
the seven yeah I think she may also burn
a weird there I can't remember but yeah
there's a lot of different places this
weirwood could be but I mean in the
culture of the first man and the old
gods the uh they often execute people in
front of weirwoods like bran has a
vision of some ancient person and and
it's got got the sort of undertones of
sacrifice to the gods and the gods are
watching through the heart tree's eyes
and so you know it maybe the Demon's
executing someone here um it'll be
really interesting to see like what role
magic and prophecy and and stuff play in
this series and that's really
interesting because Damon is like the
character who's probably least inclined
towards all of that like he he says to
rira dreams didn't make us Kings dragons
did like he's completely uninterested in
all of this prophecy and religion and
God stuff he's interested in his own
power and yet he's got that Dragon Blood
yeah and he's obsessed with the legacy
of valyria yeah so he he's got that
conflict in him he's got that dog in him
he's got that dragon in him you know
yeah and he we builds dark sister that
ancient Valyrian blade and he rides the
dragon and so I I think whether he likes
it or not he is connected to that Legacy
and that magic and so yeah it'll be
really fascinating if magic plays more
of a role with him and of course you
know rir knows about her prophecy and
there's all speculation about Lis maybe
being connected to the old gods and um
yeah the role of magic could potentially
be
interesting he appears to be beheading
someone there by the way we didn't
didn't make that clear yeah it looks
like it uh amond we we talked about this
looking at the Iron Throne hungrily he
seems to think that he's next in line I
like that there's lightning happening
there's like a storm happening how do
that work which reminds us of the Storm
at Storm's end when uh amond
accidentally killed Luke with his Dragon
um so I wonder if that sort of storm
thing is going to continue to be like a
motif with Amon yeah I mean Vaga his
Dragon the biggest dragon in Westeros is
is quite a force of nature herself you
know so I think the storm is quite a
nice aan is like constantly contending
with this with the forces of nature
that's a and he has a very stormy
personality as well he's he's like
beneath the surface he's he's raging
it's a very English teacher sort of way
of looking at this I learned everything
I know from year nine lit class um I
really like it it sort of reminds me of
the shots of Daenerys when she first
sees the iron throne in season 8
yeah mainly through the blue coloring
which we don't typically see in Kings
Landing yeah true the throne room is
normally like this warm space yeah it's
got this orange color temperature to it
whereas this yeah it's very similar in
color yeah yeah well maybe it sort of
deliberately evokes the sort of
Devastation around the throne that we
eventually see which you know was caused
by a dragon you know so we're reminded
of how a dragon can be destructive and
how can lead to um all manner of
unpleasantness such as Game of Thrones
season 8 you don't
say uh this is an interesting one it
sure is where's this it appears to be in
the north
somewhere
um these people wearing what appeared to
be black cloak so they could be Nights
Watch recruits but those people in the
middle there look very small and young
or it might be just be the comparison
cuz the people on the sides are on
horses um yeah looks very very cold
there's tall growth trees there so it's
in you know old unemp place it really
makes me think it is the North and we
know Jae is going to the north to try
and win craen Stark's Ally ship for his
mother so I no yeah I agree with that I
like the idea that these could be
recruits I it would be really cool to
see the Nights Watch in like better
times you know because the Nights Watch
has been in Decline for Centuries by the
time of the main series have far fewer
people they are far less respected than
they used to be as an seriously when
Cersei his petitions to you know help
the knights watch adult she's like LOL
yeah no but there was a time when they
were respected a bit more um I mean
wasn't you know Jaris and his Queen
alisin didn't they make an effort to
supply the Nights Watch with more men
and resources and this is that was only
two generations before this yeah like
it's a long time ago but not that long
yeah so it' be really cool to see the
Nights Watch as a more powerful
respected institution and the things
that might have been going on there cuz
like the other thing about the Nights
Watch decline is that they have lost
knowledge you know like like Jill
Mormont complains that you know we
should have known that Dragon glass can
kill White Walkers we should have like
had all these patrols and all this
information because supposedly the
Nights Watch was founded some 8,000
years ago for the purpose of Defending
Westeros against the White Walkers
apparently um but there's all sorts of
mysteries around out in the main series
is they think that they're defending
Westeros from the wildlings yeah they've
completely lost that yeah that's true
yeah they've basically forgotten their
purpose entirely by the time of the main
Series so you know given that the house
of the dragon show has introduced these
ideas like Aon the Conqueror had a dream
about the white walkers and that's why
he wants to conquer Westeros uh I wonder
if the kns watch may also have some sort
of more information and more knowledge
about their purpose and about the white
walkers and um we could learn more about
all of that um I love all the mysteries
about the night Ford and the black gate
and all of that stuff and I think Jay's
talking to Craig would be a great Avenue
to explore some of these things about an
older North yeah yeah yeah learning
about Northern politics in this era
could be fascinating um the Starks
before Ned before it's just going to be
so great to meet another Stark you know
yeah absolutely I mean you know one of
George Martin's other little series is
the Duncan egg Tales which is also being
adapted into a TV show right now um and
there are three Duncan egg stories but
one of the upcoming Duncan egg stories
because that's such a strong word I know
um but George Martin has plans to write
additional Duncan egg stories one of
which is set in Winterfell in the north
and he almost finished it apparently the
it's called She Wolves of Winterfell is
the working title and it's about like a
northern inheritance dispute for
Winterfell so this so this is in the
time period in between House of the dra
and the main Game of Thrones series um
so yeah I just yeah I just really enjoy
seeing these like familiar places and
families in different time periods is
really fun yeah it's like the excitement
you get when you meet um the Lannister
twins in season one of House of the
Dragon oh my God that guy becomes
Jamie Yeah well yeah like um I wonder if
there's a Lannister genetic
predisposition for twins absolutely
there is there there are more Lannister
twins than the General Public potion per
capita and I think that is actually
consistent with real world genetics
where twins occur more in families where
twins occur is that right I believe so
so like yeah there's some genetic
predisposition for uh fetuses to
goo that's the technical definition
isn't it uh our next shot is of Allison
a this shot's so crazy look at that you
know white dress looking so pale and
ethereal and there's fog in the
background where is this gliders um this
is in Middle Earth somewhere it would
appear yeah that was my feeling I she
just looks so pensive and not of this
world yeah I mean my thought seeing this
was the God's eye Lake yeah but like H
how does Allison wind up there near
Haron Hall I mean it's it's very weird
for her to be like standing out in the
open during this it's weird for her to
not be in the red keep ever yeah exactly
um because if she's standing out in the
open it's entirely possible that a
bloody dragon is going to come down and
scoop her up right and in episode 10
Damon says that he's going to take Haren
hle yeah yeah so yeah I mean I I kind of
like the idea that it's the God's eye
but it doesn't really make any sense for
Allison to be I don't know where else it
could be it's not the blackwat it
doesn't feel like it should be the
Blackwater and is it could it be
Blackwater Bay
like I guess it could be the bay doesn't
the city back onto the the B though like
like where's the city like maybe she's a
bit down the on the king's wood she
could be near rosby or something but
yeah so so it's it's very odd so I think
our feeling is that this might be a
dream um which could be a really
interesting way to explore her feelings
and stuff because like in the Game of
Thrones books there are constantly
dreams and visions that give us all
sorts of insights into how characters
are feeling and like visions of the
future and fears and doubts it happens
all the time in the books and they
almost never did dreams in the show
um so it would be really fitting if they
used some dream sequences in the show
especially given how the meaning of
dreams was emphasized in the first
season yeah yeah because viseris had the
dream that he would have a son and that
motivated him to have his wife cut open
and all the horrors that followed and
Helena
taryan uh says all these little
prophecies that are probably connected
to taryan Dragon dreams cuz the tarians
have this sort of genetic predisposition
to prophetic visions and and and I mean
you know if if you'll allow me to be uh
speculative what if I don't allow you
for a moment uh the high Towers right
Allison is of house high tower in the
books if I remember correctly the high
Towers uh are described as being blonde
um and having those sorts of valan
features do they have those purple eyes
as well um I think that's more of a Dane
thing I don't know if Isa really got
into about the high Towers yeah no yeah
I don't think the eyes are mentioned but
they do have silver gold hair and pale
skin leness hiow who was jorah's wife
looked like Daenerys Targaryen um and
Aller hiow has silver hair even though
she's not old enough to have like white
hair Jaris in the books Old King Jaris
confused Allison our Allison for his
daughter Sarah Targaryen who had the who
had the pale hair which he was a dying
old man at the time so grain of salt
yeah maybe that doesn't tell us so much
but but I think based on the sort of
vague information in the books it sounds
as though the high Towers look like
targaryens or at least have the the you
know silver gold hair and the reason why
I think that matters uh potentially is
that the high Towers live uh in Oldtown
all the way over here all the way over
here um which uh is also near starall um
and starall the Danes have that gold
hair they also have purple eyes even
though the books say they are not
Valyrian they are like first men or or
something um but there's also the high
tower were there long long long before
the targaryens came to Westeros yeah so
we have these like blonde people um
before the tarians and we also have the
high tower
Blackstone uh first Fort which appears
to have been made by dragons but not by
the tarians not by the valyrians Legend
of dragons roosting on Battle Isle
before the high Towers conquered it and
started Oldtown yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so in high tower HQ there's evidence of
ancient dragons before the valyrians and
they've got silver gold hair and they
got silver gold hair and the Danes have
silver gold hair and the purple eyes and
if you consider that before the arm of
Dawn was shattered if you were going to
like sail along the southern coast of
this continent and Dawn is a desert the
first place you would land is Starfall
and then the whisper the that that sound
whose name I've forgotten or you could
fly the whispering sound yeah because
the Game of Thrones world book also
talks about the great Empire of the Dawn
which were Dragon Riders probably
because they built the first forts the
so Dragon Riders before the valyrians
there's hints that someone taught the
valyrians how to ride dragons and so
there's a lot of speculation that there
was this ancient Eastern Empire that
rode dragons before the valyrians and I
think based on the hints of the high
tower and the Danes and all of that they
may have been here and so the high tower
with their blonde hair and the Danes
with their blonde hair and purple eyes
may be like the ancestors the distant
ancestors of these ancient dragon riters
which is an incredibly roundabout way of
saying maybe Allison and Otto and the
high Towers have a little drop of that
like ancient dragon rer magic blood and
maybe they have a touch of that Dragon
dreaming uh prophetic Vision ability and
that would connect with Leon High Tower
who we mentioned earlier right like
connection to to Magic Lon and mad
malora have a connection to Magic and so
it's plausible I think that the high
Towers also have a bit of that magic
blood and um therefore it makes a kind
of bit of additional sense that Allison
might have some kind of prophetic
dreams that that was quite speculative
but uh it's a fun idea I've never seen a
more succinct summary of all of that
nonsense yeah I've had a bit of practice
trying to explain that one it's so um it
it's really convoluted yeah I'm trying
very hard to make this easy to
understand uh so yeah Allison obviously
uh has been through a lot um and is
probably going to go through more uh
like season one is very much about her
relationship with reier who was her
BFF uh but they became
estranged uh because R lied about having
sex with Christen Cole and Allison
married her dad which was sort of uncool
in near his eyes a bit not great and
Otto sort of groomed Allison as this you
know political figure and her son Aon um
and ultimately she sort of convinced
herself that King viserys's dying wish
was for her son aegon to be king um and
she started relying on people like Laris
and Kristen who are murderers and not
great dudes uh and so you know Allison
despite all that did try to figure out a
peaceful resolution to this conflict
with R in the final episodes of season 1
but uh alas that does not seem to be
working out so I guess some of the
questions are you know like is peace
still possible between rer and Allison
like what love is still there if they
could just talk to each other you know
what might result um those are some of
the questions peace violence love hate
uh she wants to protect her
children what's going to happen
next a war between k
a war between Ken rineer is looking
angry got got old Cyrax behind her there
facing off with another
dragon now this is a really interesting
one
cuz it looks like like the color palette
makes me think that it's seasmoke that
other Dragon there but sea smoke is you
know like supposedly an ally of the
blacks as much as a dragon can be
counted on for you know their uh
Alliance um but it's bigger than Cyrax
and in in show Cannon Cyrax is older
than sea smoke or at least should be if
it correlates the age of their writers I
mean if we assume that the dragon
hatched at the same time that the baby
was born which is not necessarily true
it's somewhat of an assumption
yeah yeah and I mean so maybe some
dragons are just bigger than others you
know like I mean Caris is a funny
sausage noodle like maybe dragons are
just different sometimes maybe Cyrax is
just a little small girl yeah maybe Cy
sea Smoke's just real hungry yeah or
maybe it's not sea smoke well yeah I
mean that that head I mean SE smoke has
a hilarious face
yeah um and big curvy horns and I don't
I don't see that yeah true here I mean
who else could it be could it be
Silverwing yeah yeah maybe it's
Silverwing cuz Sil Wing was the uh
dragon of good Queen
Aline and this does look somewhat silver
does look very silver and who is this
person in front of this Dragon we're
debating the identity of yeah it's uh
hello definitely a person I can tell
from the pixels that it's a person they
appear to be like standing off against
each other um on this beach or sandb bar
which we know there are some of near
Dragon stone or on Dragon Stone yeah it
well it looks like an interesting
meeting like it looks like they're not
like about to murder each other it looks
like it might be more of a diplomatic
meeting or an uncertain confrontation I
mean I mean sea smoke sea smoke makes a
lot of sense because it's like she would
be uncertain about SE smoke if Coke came
back like if her ex husband came back
you know her Dragon comes back it's like
what is the Loyalty of this Dragon what
is the implication for my secret about
Lor being alive maybe that is Lor yeah
maybe Lor just came right back and said
I changed my mind a lot of people think
that Lor could come back for the war
yeah which would be insane well as I
said I mean it it is weird the idea that
se smoke could be claimed by anyone else
yeah what if what if rira just murders
Lor so that she can have sea smoke for
her side that would be mental it would
be fully mental and again like you know
these deviations from the books create
some interesting possibilities so I'm
really excited to see the fate of sea
smoke yeah yeah me too just want to see
his goofy face again this is a beautiful
shot of King's Landing yeah we don't
normally see this angle do we I remember
in uh Game of Thrones episode one
there's a sort of an unusual angle that
we get on from the side yeah well like
from the bay um yeah I quite like it we
get like this shot and you can see the
the ruined Dragon pit yep over and
there's the uh that Bor sep behind it
yeah it looks like a Proto Bor set
before they decided what it looked like
yeah
and now we see the dragon pit as it was
before dot dot dot um
so yeah so it's nice to see that shot at
King's Landing it's yeah there's like a
flying aerial shot almost I wonder if
this is a dragon flying towards just a
misiz on S like I I just think it's a
misiz on who well it's an establishing
shot of Kings Landing that's what I
think it is cuz Dragon shots are usually
Whooper than this yeah well it could
increase in whoop AG I suppose it could
become Whooper as it goes on who's this
honestly couldn't tell you so um I think
that this is Alice Rivers played by is
it Gail Ranken I think is her name the
actress um uncharacteristically I've
been caught off guard and don't know the
actor yeah I I I think it's her eye
color certainly the same veryy much does
look like it um she's got some
interesting stuff on her face by the
looks of it H what's going on with her
face are they scars are they wrinkles it
looks a bit like BN scars or something
to me it it connects with her hair
almost is it hair on her face guess it
could be and there's also things moving
through the air around her looks like
Embers or Ash or
debris leaves leaves flying through the
wind soaked snow confetti could it be
rice could it be like leaves uh blown
about by dragon wings
perhaps so so we won't tell you any uh
big spoilers but just to briefly
introduce this character this character
Alice Rivers is a bastard of house
strong apparently so you'll remember
that how strong is um is uh Harwin
strong and Laris
strong uh the children of Lionel strong
um and lonel strong was handed the king
and uh Lara strong is now the like sort
of Master of Whispers for
alicent um and how and strong was the
father of uh Jace Luke and Joffrey
Reiner's
kids and so important family important
family um Lords of heren Hall an old
first men family which you know are the
people with the blood of the skin
changes and the Ws which is why the sort
of like um lus being magical potentially
mix and
um and Alice is this
mysterious um witch King all right
everyone in the live chat is saying it's
Helena could that be Helena I thought it
was Alice Rivers it doesn't doesn't look
like um yeah it doesn't look like Helena
to
me
um is it
Helena oh I get her chin and her mouth
looks similar her eyebrows look
similar people are saying it's Helena
beneath a
veil yeah all right I could see that
well the chat seems to think it's
Helena those are the same earrings no
they're
not yeah well it's a very interesting
shot yeah whatever whoever it is should
we keep talking about Alice Rivers
anyway well she she's not in the trailer
yeah look Alice Rivers is a cool bastard
witch who uh we will learn more
about um and everyone seems to think
this is
Helena uh well let's talk about Helena
then shall we who who no hel I I really
liked Helena Targaryen The Queen of
aegon the second um in the first season
what do you love about
Helena
um she she doesn't take no gut from
anyone no um I really like that she's
she's just so different from every other
character um with a um like unmitigated
just I I'll blurt out a prophecy to you
now I don't know what it means you don't
know what it means the audience is going
to try to figure it out it's just a lot
of fun
um and she's got this like sort of
detached apathy about everything going
like it's just I'm I'm here I guess they
made me marry my brother we have some
children I guess I'm the queen now but
where the Beast beneath her oh my god um
she's just a pure innocent Soul who
doesn't deserve any hardships ever she
yeah she's a great contrast to most of
the other characters she's innocent cuz
most of the other characters yeah like
she hasn't done anything yeah yeah
that's so true cuz every other character
has blood on their hands or just has
made some terrible lawful decisions in
their pursuit of love and power and you
know Legacy whereas Helena has done none
of those things yeah and in Her speech
in episode 8 she talks about her
marriage to aegon and she's like look
look this is my lot I'm dealing with it
yeah yeah she show she showed a lot of
awareness there like in the earlier
episodes Helena seemed to like not even
necessarily be aware of what's happening
around her most of the time whereas yeah
in that in that moment she actually
she's acutely aware of what's going on
yeah she like tells us that yeah like
I'm aware that my husband King Aon my
husband brother is awful um but you know
uh I'm seeing the bright side you deal
with it and I deal with it and um and
yeah she's also magic let's see how she
continues to deal with it yeah what else
will she have to deal with I really
really liked this yeah the dancing scene
yeah very gorgeous cuz like in the same
way that Allison and rira have some
distant love for each other like this
showed that there could have been a nice
connection between the next generation
of this feud in the family yeah Family
Feud if you if you may yeah Ju Just like
like um how the intergenerational hatred
was passed down to the children there
was also some love that was passed down
to the children you know like at the
same time that they passed down this
awful Feud they also passed down a sort
of an affection and the possibility that
it could be rekindled so I think they've
done a good job of like giving us a
sense of hope that you know maybe it's
possible that these guys could um
reconcile somehow and do a little boogie
once
more so yeah I mean you know given that
Helena uh doesn't seem happy here seems
to have these prophecies yeah she does
not look too happy you know what those
creases wrinkles on her face really do
it it does make sense that it's a veil
like I can see that now yeah it's weird
it's so thin and so transparent that it
looks like it's like part of her skin
it's a very when I first saw this shot I
was like wait are we underwater yeah
yeah it's a very strange dreamy shot
which fits very strange strange dreamy
character
um yeah I wonder what will happen with
Helena next cuz I mean she's also don't
she's well I mean hotti has I mean like
in the books Helena is not a magic
person as far as we know like Helena
having dreams and Visions is an
invention of the show so you know even
those of us who have read the books and
know the basic things that are going to
happen we don't know the details and the
specifics which are often just as
important as the big things you know
given that she does have some foresight
into the future whatever happens to
Helena next she probably sort of has
some idea of already yeah yeah which is
just terrible and and like you know the
whole way that the whole way that dreams
work in this series is that um often
characters follow their dreams and their
visions and they try to fulfill their
prophecies they try and make them come
true but they often find out that it
comes true in a different way than what
they expected often with tragic and
disastrous results which I which I think
is basically a metaphor or a device to
explore Ambitions and dreams and hopes
and consequence of foll your ambition
and dreams and hopes and and so Helena
is kind of an interesting contrast to
that because so she is not a character
who really pursues dreams and hopes like
her Visions are just something that she
just has and she just sort of mutters
them for other people to hear which I
guess makes her more similar to
characters like patch face um yeah who's
another character who doesn't really do
much but he just says these prophetic
things for other characters to be
disturbed by or really the reader I mean
patch I mean the reader reacts to patch
is prophecies more everyone else is like
ah that goofy little guy so I guess one
of the other questions is like will
anyone listen to Helena's prophecies
this season or will she continue to be
mostly ignored throughout season one she
has been shown to be ignored basically
all the time yeah like when she was
telling her mother cool facts about this
millipede she just was like yep imagine
not being interested in Helena's
milipede facts that's just
outrageous so yeah we love Helena and
we'll see what happens next uh we got a
drum boom boom something's happening
here we got some Riders this definitely
looks like I mean that looks like a
King's Guard KN doesn't it it sure does
that's a white cloak yep King's Guard KN
riding through the forest could be a
battle could be a messenger could be a
secret mission there's one dripped out
horse we won't spoil anything too
important but we do see a
battle do we see any particular heraldry
here I don't think we do I'm not picking
up on any except for the you know all
the white adornments of that horse there
there is something in the bottom left
there that we might be able to make out
I wonder who that horse is what's that
horse's name is that a rosby yeah those
are the red stripes oh my god of rosby
aren't they to yeah yeah so so this
looks like a continuation of the um
rosby and stokeworth soldiers that we
saw over here y same helmets and stuff
as well so so yeah I mean that's got
blood on the shields so maybe that's
like maybe this is like after the battle
or after a battle and this is during the
battle yeah could be and given that the
rosb and stok worth so with the greens
this Mak sense that this could be
Kristen
uh yeah it's nice to see characters
actually wearing their helmet is thank
God because um that was another
complaint about the got TV show is that
I mean in episode three when Damon makes
his suicide run in the stepstones he
doesn't wear helmet yeah like that's
sort of dumb but well that well that's
because he was being ridiculous and YOLO
and suicidal yeah and he and if and
wearing a helmet wouldn't make his I'm
surrendering thing very convincing so
they're using PL props to tell stories
and tell us things about characters
which is storytelling vent to do who
would have thought I love it um yeah so
it looks like we got more battles so
this is probably in the crown lands um
woohoo battles and yeah it looks as
though the stokeworth and rosb are
siding with uh the greens and aegon
against rera by the looks of it based on
the heraldry earlier so we will see how
that develops and oh my gosh that's fire
I know that from real life wait a minute
there's dragons in this story burning a
wagon or something yeah so there's more
rosb shields in there the rosb are just
eating L's today they sure are I mean
that's what they do all through the
series if we're being honest I think it
just turns out that being like a minor
house in the shadow of the tarians just
bad idea just a bad time I would not
want to the T actually that doesn't
really work out that well either so I
guess one question is like which dragon
is doing the roasting of the rosb here
well we've seen um cyra's flame we've
seen corus's flame we've seen SE smok's
flame and have we seen any of M's flame
I don't think we have are you telling me
that you can identify a dragon based on
the appearance of its fire yeah and I'm
about to oh my gosh um cuz that well
please don't ask me to do that cuzz
that's not going to happen well that is
a thing in the books though isn't it
because in the books the different
dragons have different colored flame
yeah Isn't that cool drogon breathes
black flame Reon Regal breathes yellow
and green flame been talking for a while
haven't we we sure have um so that's so
you actually can tell dragons apart by
their fire in the books sometimes but
probably not here because this is you
know real life fire enhanced by computer
Imaging of course but I I I don't know
how they convince those actors to be set
a fire for this show but um there is
this cool artwork by the inimitable OU
alteras um of Tarion breathing blue
flame beautiful uh which is pretty cool
um although I suppose we should not get
too specific about what that event is
but the point is that yeah there are
different colored fiery dragons in the
books uh yeah so I mean of course one of
the things about this war is that uh the
soldiers and armies but the dragons can
basically roast everyone one of the
lessons from agon's Conquest uh is that
dragons beat armies almost every time
like as we saw in Game of Thrones uh
dragons can be killed with things like
Scorpion ballistas and in the daish wars
that aegon attempted in his conquest of
dawn um the way that the dorish won
against his dragons was by not engaging
with them yeah yeah it is possible to
beat dragons um by just avoiding them
and striking when uh they least expect
and getting a few lucky shots with
ballista so uh so yeah like it's this
weird sort of asymmetrical Warfare with
dragons and armies um and something they
discussed in episode 10 is that uh they
could go out with dragons and try and
burn all the armies but the dragons have
to be well the dragons are usually
piloted by people by targaryens who are
important Royal people and so rir
doesn't want to risk her family by
having them ride into battle on the
backs of dragons especially when half
the Dragon Riders are kids yep her
kids yeah so it's like we've got these
powerful weapons but the only way of
using these weapons is by risking her
children so it's you know it's almost
like it's it's almost like George wrote
this to be as dramatic and and violent
as
possible Ah that's why you have multiple
children
yeah that's right more tarians some them
can die in war and it won't matter mhm
uh so being roasted by dragons is not
fun uh and then we see Rainy telling
riera hey this war is going to be bad
because there's dagron oh which is like
an extension of what she says to call
this in episode one of House of House of
the Dragon she's
like yeah no one is really grasping like
we're playing at War here this isn't no
one's getting the gravity of War yeah
yeah that that's important because this
has not really happened before there has
never been a like tarian Civil War at
this scale there's no like memory of
dragons fighting dragons um yeah this
sort of thing would have happened in the
days of old valyria but not since then
yeah it's it's certainly not in like
living memory um like the the closest
thing that sort of happened was uh Meo
the cruel who was um a son of aegon the
first the Conqueror um killed one of his
was it his nephew um uh and so that was
a dragon on Dragon tug Arian on tuaran
battle that happened but that was just
one dragon and one dragon and one battle
yeah that was one very brief moment now
we've got like almost 20 dragons flying
around yeah so the potential for Carnage
is
enormous um this is like you know two
nuclear Powers um just starting to fling
thermonuclear icbms at each other so uh
so yeah Duck and
Cover um get beneath your
table and so you know R stop drop and
roll yeah so rainy uh is great are we
rainy fans I think we're rainy fans I'm
a Raines fan she's great because she was
almost the ruler of
Westeros uh but at the Haron Hall
Council they chose viseris instead and
you know we can wander all day at how
much better off we may have been if
raining ruled Westeros instead of Aeris
um or worse off who knows um but you
know she she was spurned by the Lords
and she has a certain bitterness about
that um partly you know her actor was
saying that uh rise kind of hates reera
because rera was named as heir to the
throne and Rise wasn't and so there's a
bit of jealousy there well in this scene
rise says Serena um yeah good luck with
that yeah yeah and and we've just now
reached the yeah that's the look isn't
it and we've just now reached the point
where riro will be needing good luck
with that and R Is Now by her side to
counsel her and provide some of that
well-wishing that she needs and a dragon
yeah it's a weird situation where rain e
was previously not really in Rainer
corner but now they are bound together
well you know um there's a scene where
there are a few scenes where CES and
rainy have a chat about their Ambitions
in the future of their family and rainy
says look I've made my Pace with that it
happened a very long time ago I have put
the business behind me yeah and I think
that's sincere I think that she means it
when she says that she's not making that
up just to get her husband to do what
she wants yeah yeah no she means it but
the emotions aren't all gone yeah um
like it is UN it is literally unfair
that R was the air to the iron throne
and Rise wasn't yeah rise was rejected
for being female riro was not so so it
makes complete sense that she'd be
bitter about that and of course you know
I mean half this goddamn problem is that
the tarians couldn't decide on a system
and on a precedent for inheritance like
if they just decided okay women are or
are not allowed to inherit if they just
stuck to something then there'd be a
much more stable round that's what the
purpose of the council basically was to
determine the Precedence and then
viseris was like I don't like my brother
that much or at least I don't trust him
to um be be the next king if I die I I
don't hate in Game of Thrones season 8
the idea of having a great council at
the end of the story to choose a king um
because it's it's a step towards
accountability and something almost
resembling democracy almost in vague
distant sense off in the Horizon that
might be a democracy someday there's
that there's hints that before Robert's
Rebellion uh rhaegar Taren was hoping to
call a council uh to remove his father
the Mad King ays from the throne to um
possibly put himself on the throne but
like to do so with the support and
consent of the great houses instead of
just unilaterally having a mad man on
the Iron Throne um a soft coup in the
direction of a more peaceful rulership
yeah a soft CP in a good direction is
sort of the Hope um so something like
that happening at the end of A Song of
Ice and Fire makes some sense to me just
not in who has a better story oh my
goodness yeah I uh did not like uh the
way that was handled at the end of The
Game of Thrones TV show that's such a
brave and unique Viewpoint you have
there I know I'm a special butterfly but
I did not love uh a lot about how that
went down in season 8 um but yeah anyway
rainy really I couldn't tell from your
videos on the subject I
know I was I was subtle I know uh so
rainy you know one of the other
complications is that you know rainy has
lost both of her children um she has
lost uh her daughter Lena and her son
Lor has since died in the time since
this chart was made uh well I mean she
thinks Lor's dead yeah uh but rainy does
still have her grandchildren Baylor and
Raina wouldn't it suck to have Damon as
a son-in-law uh she deals with it oh my
God she tries to ignore it I think so
Bay is the one with the dragon rain is
the one without a dragon um and rain's
would like bayor and Raina to inherit
drift Mark um and to rule that second
most powerful house but also you know
there's the question of maybe Joffrey
valion might potentially rule the uh
valion and drift Mark well especially
now that Luke's dead now that Luke's
dead and he was meant to be the person
so you know there's still that sort of
valion power struggle is is a it
continues to be a thing you think Raina
is going to be sad she seemed to really
like Luke yeah yeah cuz Raina was
betrothed to marry Luke um just as Bayo
was betro to marry Jace yeah um still is
yeah so I want yeah Will Raina be betro
to Joffrey now instead we're going to
know I don't really see the point of
having a double betral going on because
like established one Alliance and that's
good enough yeah putting putting all of
your chips yeah it basically leads to
the situation where Luke can't give
Boris Baratheon anything yeah yeah
exactly yeah if they didn't make that
double betral Luke could have said okay
boros I will marry one of your although
in saying that boros's daughters were
like 30 and Luke's like 14 again not the
worst political marriage that has
occurred in this series um so yeah
rainey's has a lot going on she mostly
just wants to protect her family and she
doesn't really want and innovates new
dramatic
hairstyles yes just look at this it's
incredible she sure does um but at the
same time we should remember that uh
rise is
badass um and she's a chaotic
mfer and her Dragon was said to be the
fastest dragon in Westeros at one
point um and uh she's just she's just
cool and I hope that we get to see some
of her coolness
soon some epic dramatic rainy stuff we
see
bayor yeah so this is reis's
granddaughter Damon and Lena's daughter
bayor twin of Raina uh she has a little
dragon called moondancer well we
actually don't know if she's little in
the show yeah we haven't seen Moon
Dancer in the TV show yet um but this uh
carefully photosho uh it's carefully
cropped uh image uh is a is a butchered
version of a magali vnu uh illustration
of Moon Dancer so she's a sort of pale
green small Serpentine dragon in the
books uh but yeah we're yet to see what
she looks like in this really reminds me
of Lena riding Vega in episode 6 yeah
there's a similar expression there isn't
there I think so um what else do we know
about bayor we don't know a whole lot
about B she seems to be the more like
um confident
outgoing sibling between herself and
raino because um yeah yeah this sort of
feeling um raino of course doesn't have
a dragon and that that's a thing that
targaryens are sort of you know their
strength is defined by their connection
to dragons and Raina doesn't have one so
she's more like Meek
um and you know doesn't really get up to
much whereas B is a lot she seems a lot
more Fierce than raino yeah we we really
didn't see much of them in season one
unfortunately so it'll be interesting to
see what kinds of characterization they
get excited to see more of them yeah saw
them kneeling to Raina at the end of
season
one um so yeah we we'll see like if they
start participating in battles we'll see
if Raina gets a dragon we'll see if they
uh get to marry any of R's kids there's
a lot of possibilities with these guys
so we'll see what happens I wonder if
like Raina will want to like steal a
dragon get a dragon egg well I
hypothesize that she should be the one
that might want to try and claim sea
smoke yeah that would make a lot of
sense and if that works then that would
be the tip to rero that Lenor has died
off screen yeah no that's a great idea
that would make a lot of sense they have
a lot of options concerning um the
future of these characters the fact that
uh Baylor is screaming at Top This
Dragon suggests that she's in battle oh
she could just be enjoying it's like
when you scream on a roller Coter aan
screamed when he claimed Vega she looks
pretty angry yeah she does oh and look
at that uh pin that she's wearing that
looks just like
daenerys's pin in the latest seasons of
the TV show that's interesting let's see
if I can find do you remember which
episodes she has
that gosh it's so probably season 7
episode 4 season 7 episode
4 and then eight e13 oh Mandi mandai has
oh there it is there it goes so was that
daen I hate this scene so much I banged
the
unic look at me you have a crush on Jon
Snow no I don't shut up I mean it was it
was kind of like an important scene
because like establishing that daen and
Mandi like have an important
relationship and a friendship is really
important before mandi's death um but
yeah I don't think it I don't think it
landed the way that they executed it
unfortunately yeah that's the that looks
the same it's it's the three dragon
heads um is this some sort of you know
like advisor to the queen
symbolism I wonder if we'll see this
thing explained at all that is basically
the same prop I mean it's
backwards yeah or is it yeah no Taran
yeah huh cool cool I I'm Ryan Condell
probably loves that we're noticing this
because you just know that Ryan was like
they were saying Ryan Ryan no one's
going to notice that it's the same
dragon head pin as last time and Ryan
was like don't you worry Ryan Ryan has
seen enough reactions to the painted
table to know that people care about the
props yeah I hope so I I I mean it would
be such a weird position being like a
showrunner of a show like this and the
question of like do I or do I not look
at all the youtubs do I cud all the
weird nerds who spend their entire lives
thinking about this stuff cuz that's one
of the mistakes that Westworld made was
that they decided to uh write their show
entirely for the Reddit nerds and to be
like ah yes the average audience member
will definitely want to go onto our
Secret website to find the Easter egg
that leads to the clue that leads to the
Facebook chat bot that tells them what
that entire episode was about like they
really made it difficult for people to I
think there's a healthy Middle Ground
between all of that ARG stuff and um
contempt for the audience that uh Benny
off and Weiss seem to demonstrate
towards the end of Game of Thrones yeah
yeah because yeah because D and D did
the opposite of what westwell did and
they catered only to the people who
don't know the character's names and
like you know have no interest in any of
the details when they see a dragon do
something yeah obviously I mean I do
that too yeah obviously the middle
ground is both like there we want to woo
at the dragons and we want to appreciate
the small you if there's some a ARG crap
that you want people to be able to
indulge themselves in like give that but
don't make it too important yeah yeah
exactly don't make the um understanding
of the show's entire meaning rely on
access to it yeah you you've got to try
and thread that needle and appeal to M
unless like willing to deal with the
Fallout of making it that exclusive
that's fine like well and also like if
you are trying to appeal to an Ultra
small Niche audience maybe don't spend
$100 million on
it like if you're trying if if making a
return on your investment is a goal
maybe try to appeal to more than five
guys on
Reddit as one of those five
guys I beseech you all right um the
other four are going to have words for
when I see when next time I see the
other um so so Bay's having a yell the
the way these shots are ordered makes it
look like Baylor is flying her Dragon
over King's Landing and scaring the
people which is interesting because if
you roll the shots backwards it sort of
looks like Baylor is in that battle with
the rosb and the St if you run them
backwards it looks like Bay's flying
backwards away from the she's leaving
King's Landing um yeah so so it's
deliberately ambiguous what's going on
there but but seeing all these like see
seeing all these fleeing civilians
reminds me of season 8 episode 5 where
Daenerys decides to do a war crime and
uh we see all of the fleeing civilians
running away from
her which is um maybe a deliberate
parallel that they're doing oh well
perhaps oh well oh well oh well oh well
um so yeah I mean what's going on here
why why are all these civilians running
around glidus because there's stuff
happening and like people panic when
stuff happens I find stuff to be very
panicky um so so the they grabbing
they're grabbing Allison they're
grabbing the Queen Mother the queen
mother so that of course is similar to
the riot in Game of Thrones season 2
episode oh God is it five or six six six
God you're good at that um so this was
the riot that happened because the
common people were hungry and not a big
fan of King Joffrey and the opulence
exuded by the royal family and so the
King's Guard struggled to protect the
Royals from the common people and sort
of just gave up on protecting
Sansa yes until sandor was like n let's
let's keep her alive I guess so
similarly uh it looks like the common
people are grumpy with Allison and the
greens um something that I War tends to
be a catalyst for famine and things of
this nature yeah and while the Royals
are prioritizing the war and
prioritizing their own safety they might
not be looking after the common folk
what one of the things that isn't in the
books but which I really liked in Hot D
was this idea of mazaria as like a
champion for the common people um
because she spoke to Otto and she's like
hey like you know you have no power but
what the people allow you and you need
to close the fighting pits and you need
to respect the the common innocent
average people and of course you know
there was that moment in episode 9 when
rise and Mel murdered a bunch of
civilians in the dragon completely
disregarding the well-being of the
normal people who live in the city so I
think that I think that's meant to be a
Counterpoint to mazaria saying hey you
need to respect the power of the common
people so by seeing this this Riot
happening and people grabbing Allison I
think that's all meant to connect as a
way of saying this is the consequence of
not respecting the common people and you
know the the the fate of the the normal
folks is thematically wrapped up in
Targaryen power and disregard for um
their status yeah so we'll see how that
plays out cuz like in in theory the
whole idea to justify this feudal
hierarchy is that there's a social
contract and the contract is that the
Royals have the power and they use that
power to protect the common people to
provide basic security make your life
better than it would be if we weren't
there you pay your taxes and you get
some kind of protection in return in
theory that's the system and good rulers
uphold that contract and bad rulers fail
to uphold that contract that's a biting
political commentary I know um so when
the common people start trying to um rip
you apart that's a sign that you might
be failing for you might have dropped
the ball on that one Chief you might
have done a few whoopsies yeah all right
what's next I don't know you're the one
with the with the control here this is a
Bracken Soldier see a little red horsey
down there yeah the brackens of course
being a house of the riverlands who are
in this constant Millennia long feud
between themselves and the blackwoods
I love this douchebag Gerald Bracken
what a guy you didn't believe me when I
said his name was Gerald I thought you
were joking it was no joke and that's a
Willam Blackwood so what happened to
Gerald uh he got he got cut up he he got
all killed and stuff on the floor of
storms end what is it with storms end
and lordlings killing each other over
intergenerational beef I think that just
dramatic uh environment just encourages
dramatic yeah
doings dark turbulent bloody doings I I
like that we saw a Bracken shield in uh
season one didn't we when the Tyrion and
Catlin get attacked by the hill tribes
in the veil so yeah this is a Bracken
and uh it looks as though uh conflict
continues what who's fighting who I mean
maybe this is related to uh the
Blackwood killing the Bracken in episode
four that was like 20 years ago yeah
that's true uh but it's you know it's a
nice maybe we'll see Willam Blackwood
again and is finally facing consequences
you know someone's like you killed our
our Lord's son or whatever and also you
know this is a hint that the war is
spreading like we've seen that you know
the rosb and the stoew worths indicate
that there's fighting happening in the
crown lands but seeing this Bracken
pulling out his sword suggests that the
war might be spreading to the riverlands
as well that's right when violence
breaks out it's like an excuse for other
violences to exist also yeah it's true
like like there's opportunistic violence
like every war if we pledge ourselves to
you then you'll pledge yourselves to
them and then we can have a war as well
which we've wanted to do because we hate
you yeah every war is an opportunity for
ambitious angry people to settle beef or
as put by Peter Bish Chaos's
ladder indeed um so yeah we'll see what
happens with the brackens and the
brackens are like the bad guy coded side
whereas the blackwoods are the good guy
coded side which is also funny like I
always enjoy how George Martin is like
everyone has Humanity everyone's
deserving of respect there were good
people in bad people on the side of
every war suck except for the brackens
who are all awful and the frease who are
all awful and the Bolton so were all
awful I don't think George does that
with the phrase I think he makes quite
an effort to demonstrate phaser true and
he also the boltons there's domick
Bolton who was appar a cool dude yeah so
and maybe we'll meet a cool Bracken
there's a small chance there's a there's
a possibility yeah but that is funny
that he makes titos Blackwood the
coolest guy in the world World actually
he he doesn't understand it
interview where some guy was like man I
just love titos Blackwood and George was
like I he appears in one scene and he's
just got a cloak what why do you love
this guy so much some of George Martin's
most iconic characters are iconic by
accident I I mean the alltime classic is
when uh George Martin in the comments of
his blog expressed confusion that a lot
of people are attracted to the hound and
The Hound's relationship to Sansa and
he's like but the Hound is is scary
ug so you know why would anyone be
attracted to this hot man with these
issues emotionally and this power and
danger George ever spoken to a woman
yeah there's all these like people in
the comments saying no actually that
Dynamic is incredibly attractive to a
lot of people and George is like oh damn
I wish they were attracted to Sam Fat
bookish Sam Good well-intentioned Sam
who there are people out there George
don't worry yeah um so we see some
Bernie people doing the Bernie J
yep their best Hayden Christenson
Impressions oh my god um and yeah
there's that sort of characteristic
thick clothing that is worn by the stunt
men before they get set on fire for
these sorts of shots uh dmon on a dragon
on Caris in his armor who who's he going
to fight so we mentioned that they
anyone he can yeah anyone he can get his
hands on yeah so you mentioned that
Damon's going to Haron Hall isn't he
that's what he said he'd do it's what he
wanted to do at least so Hall is the big
ruined castle that we've seen before a
very strategic location right in the
center of Westeros biggest castle on the
side of a big lake so it's near King's
Landing uh and River Rome basically
controls the
riverlands yeah so it's a great foothold
if you want to conduct a war across the
continent which Damon very much wants to
do currently the Lord of Haron Hall uh
is our buddy Laris strong not that he
ever spends any time there from the of
it yeah he's busy in King's Landing
being Ellison's master of Whisperers and
this is of course after he murdered his
father Lionel and brother harn uh so
who's in charge of Haron Hall we don't
know who's who donon going to meet at
Haren Hall we don't know we will find
out uh if that is indeed where he's
going don't touch that dial for six
months or so uh and this is an event
that is an event we will not spoil any
major events but that is Helena and
that's a guy yep we will say nothing
further so we don't spil where that guy
came from or what he's doing there this
is Kristen uh copying Damon yeah we got
to see plagiarism Kristen we got to see
Damon bash uh someone in the head uh in
season one and now we see Kristen
bashing someone in the head with a I
wonder if this is a similar situation
where it's a messenger telling him
something he doesn't like or if it's
just like someone in B he's in battle
with if it's someone he's in battle with
it's confusing that he's not stabbing
him with his sword or something like
that yeah hitting someone with your own
helmet does not look like a I am in
Mortal Kombat type of a move it's more
of a I'm superior to you and you've
displeased me sort of yeah that is an
insult of a move isn't it um it's
episode three yeah and I wonder what
that armor design like I I don't
remember seeing a an armor design like
that um
um where would you find it well to me it
sort of says Tully that armor design um
CU they have some of gu is wearing oh
maybe not yeah maybe not Tully it does
feel Riverland is for some reason yeah
maybe it's just I I love the black
fish's armor in season six yeah it does
look pretty cool so cool very scaly very
cool um so yeah Kristen continues his
legacy of just being a douche I would
not be surprised if this guy is an ally
and he's attacking his own Ally because
you know Kristen murdered Joffrey um and
he murdered uh God who else do murder he
murdered Joffrey and he murdered L be
lman be yeah rip never forgetti um so
yeah kriston continues to be a violent
douchebag um some guy's falling off a
horse he drifted too
fast uh here is who's this glidus I'm
inclined to believe this is Eric
Carill so remember there's there's Eric
and there's Eric yeah you can tell from
the from the mustache that is aric yeah
you you were saying that um I have
become pretty good at telling Luke and
Elliot didn't Zar apart but
um the footage is too blurry and you
know it's just a single still yeah well
Eric appears to be or Eric or aric
appears to be attacking someone in a
bedroom um so what's going on here looks
to be in the Red Cap actually yeah
wonder if that's connected to anything
else combat inside the red keep is a bad
sign yeah oh that's a guy with a sword
seems to be the same kind of armor yeah
anyway that's amond targarian riding
vagar presumably who's he fighting
what's he
doing uh and that's that's rer on a
dragon so yeah maybe that's connected
maybe it's not teasers like to play
around with that sort of stuff deceptive
editing the lighting and the sky it does
look very similar is it possible that
amond is fighting rer that would be
extremely dang going up against Vega the
biggest dragon alive um in the books we
don't see a lot of Raina fighting but it
looks as though that's what's happening
in the TV show so that would be cool as
well she's not wearing armor like
something that people complained about
with Daenerys is that she she not only
didn't have a saddle she she didn't even
wear armor when she was in battle on her
Dragon I think the saddle complaint is a
bit much because you know here the
targaryens have have grown up in a in a
dragon based cult like dragons are
around them all the time they've
continued on from the Valyrian Legacy of
having dragons dragons being saddled is
just the thing they do whereas Daenerys
like there are no dragons around in the
time of in season one Tyrion designed a
saddle yeah for brown yeah yeah I don't
know why they didn't pay that off in
season
seven yeah they very much could have it
just it would have made so much sense
for tyan to say hey as your hand here's
something I can do to help you here's a
thing I did in the past that relates to
a thing that's in the present they loved
doing that in season seven they love
nothing better than callbacks yeah maybe
the season 1 saddle incident was a bit
too obscure for
them um but yeah we'll see we I if if we
get a moment of rera coming out Queen
rera in her tarian armor looking as cool
as like dayon in his armor that would be
extremely R gets armor why not why not
everyone else so here's Vega uh
presumably being ridden by Ammond uh
flying over soldiers looking huge I love
how Vega eclipses the sun wonderful
imagery we see vegar tattered cuz vegar
is so old war torn veteran of a zillion
battles I like all the jokes about Vega
being like a dementia riddled old lady
who what's that is we're going to boil
the dornish Sands again woo exactly let
me get my coat and I wonder like you
know they look like the same helmets so
I wonder if this is the same battle
scene um as all of those soldiers being
roasted earlier the rosb and the
stokeworth
being roasted um I I mean based on what
we see it kind of suggests that rera and
amond are involved in the same battle
against each other above this in the
crown lands that's that's what's
suggested sure is suggested so we'll see
what happens uh fiery targaryan sigil uh
HBO TM original TM Game of Thrones TM
how hle the dragon TM summer TM 2024
copyright registered they said uh early
summer is what has been said so that's
right now well it depends on the
hemisphere glidus uh so June I think is
when this might all start and Al shift X
will make uh weekly live streams and
weekly videos and glidus will make some
timely
videos yeah I mean yeah what what are
your plans oh I'd like to make look I
tried doing the weekly thing in season
one and it fell apart when I caught Co
and died for a little bit but oh that
sucks yeah um and and it's only been a
year and a bit and I finally wrapped it
up um hopefully season two won't take me
that long there are only eight episodes
of this season I believe yeah eight
episode season
so and and hopefully there's not enough
to you know hopefully there's just less
themes and character stuff going on you
know more dragon battles to talk about
so that so that I don't have to spend
that much time thinking about it for my
videos yeah because it's just really
annoying when a show has
themes it certainly gives more work for
us but uh speaking of work for us look
at all those super chats yeah I think
that we've talked about the whole teaser
trailer now if anyone has burning
questions and topics i''d like us to
discuss we will be answering super chats
now um and we'll do our best to answer
as many as we can and we will uh not
spoil any major plot events um we might
have a very brief spoilery Corner
towards the end but we will mostly uh
just focus on some basic info of what to
expect what we're hoping to see happen
uh bit of that fun stuff so first Super
Chat thank you so much to I will be
right back sure uh thank you so much to
Alex Shen who says I think the dragon
face off is sea smoke and Cyrax yeah I
think that's where gladus and I landed
on that as well um this shot of the two
dragons facing each other uh over here I
think based on their appearance it looks
like um it looks like Rainer is Dragon
Cyrax and Lor's Dragon sea smoke of
course SE Lor has gone off into the East
so there's a lot of open questions about
like who is now in control of sea smoke
could this possibly be Lor returning
from the east or has someone else taken
sea smoke is it possible for someone
else to take sea smoke while Lor is
alive lots of open
questions thank you uh Bilbo Norway who
says Scooby and glooby do you think we
will get the steamy 50-minute long Auto
Corless makeout sesh in this season
perhaps in season 3 I have not detected
a lot of sexual tension between Otto and
callus personally I mean I don't think
they've ever really had a
conversation um in the whole show I mean
they were both on the small
Council uh for viseris when Otto was
hand and callus was uh master of ships
but uh do I expect to see them make out
in season 2 it would surprise me what
did they miss yeah it would surprise me
Bill Norway wants to know if Otto and
callus will make out oh now that's a
pairing I haven't really considered yeah
really Innovative shipping going on here
in the super chats um we will just have
to wait with baited breath to see if
that occurs I don't see them really
being in the same location for long
enough to pull that off I I don't and
like is there that Much Chemistry I mean
opposite sides of a war Forbidden love
you know I mean they're both very
ambitious men I I I see that clashing
you know I I don't see that um working
too well who who who who do we ship who
do we expect to get together here you
know
I I really like the love triangle
between rise reira and no actually the
real love triangle is kis rise and
K is in love with kis um but well
well yeah kis is is in love with the
idea of his legacy and his
self-importance yeah rainy must
sometimes feel a bit left out I know I
think a ship that really took off was um
Jason and Helena yeah yeah there's of
course the Helena and Aon
thing that people talk about Helena and
amond yeah yeah yeah it seemed as though
they had some kind of connection and it
seemed like amond was a bit jealous that
aegon gets to marry Helena and he
doesn't so I wouldn't mind marrying her
she's an
idiot yeah so I wonder what other
romances might happen I mean Jason
Baylor yeah is something that makes some
sense um but we shall see we shall
see uh thank you for the Super Chat from
Raven who says glad to catch the stream
thank you Liam who says hello Astroglide
and sh please stop calling me that
question about the episode 10 Bliss have
you chosen an Acappella intro yet and
may I suggest Your Love by The Outfield
I that's a great song um and maybe one
day I'll do it but I I chose the song
I'm doing for this episode like over a
year ago yeah yeah this this BL Series
has been long in the making I've been
working on this video for over a year
and the final one is coming out very
soon so everyone should go and subscribe
to glidus there is a link in the video
description below this stream go and sub
to glidus and press the little
bell thank you seban Maco who says
greetings shim bong belis and Glen CL
are you used to just you're just old
shift x i yeah I don't know who what
happens when you know you bring my
people along could you attempt to
pronounce that for me please greetings
shim bobulous and Glen
CU Glenn kabon Glenn cabon Glenn kabon
hello from Serbia oh that explains it do
you all read Fanfictions of he and fire
and House of dragon if so which do you
like and which are bad have you read
much fanfiction I I don't think I've
read any song of a and fire or House of
the Dragon oh I've read a little yeah
any good
stuff
no I'm sure it's out there I just like
it takes so much time who has the time
I'd love to some of them are very long I
mean very impressive people put so much
work into these things and George hates
you for it I I feel like that may have
been exaggerated all these stories of
George Martin I I mean I think George
Martin has said things along the lines
of like if you want to become a better
writer make up your own stuff yeah is
what George Martin has has said in the
past I think he's referred to it as
copyright infringement before as well
which I think he has to say for legal
reasons like I think that some authors
feel obligated to not acknowledge fan
works because that might undermine their
legal claim to their own copyrights
which because it's this really fun thing
about this legalistic dystopia that we
live in that you can't admit to liking
things because it might make you lose
your rights over your stuff I hate
Lindsay
Ellis We Hate Everything unless
otherwise yeah yeah yeah thank you for
the Super Chat from Saint na naive who
says held off on watching the teaser
until now cheers for covering it also
Glide us well done on the new Bliss take
it was almost as long as carxi name oh
this must be a supporters who already
watched it thank you very much are you
telling me that supporters of glidus on
patreon.com can get early access to
videos such as the long awaited Bliss
take for episode 10 not just that Mr
shift but so do so too do YouTube
members and twitch Subs not that anyone
cares about twitch Subs oh well if you'd
like to support glidus in his efforts
you can support him on patreon or
elsewhere it'll be coming out in like 12
hours don't worry about or at least it
should be if YouTube doesn't sync it
again you also might like to support Al
shift X on patreon uh because there
isn't old shiftx patreon at
patreon.com shiftx it sure is wow um on
the uh Pat the live stream tier of
patreon supporters we've been doing
monthly live streams talking about the
real John Snow video that is 90%
finished uh and will be out sometime in
the near future so uh so that's exciting
too you mean tomorrow right I do not
mean tomorrow oh thanks for the Super
Chat from SS who says do you think jeris
knows about agon's prophecy by now I
think if that would have H I think if
that were to have happened we would have
been shown it right yeah because like
the the show did put a lot of emphasis
on who does and does not know about
aegon's prophecy about the White Walker
coming um because viseris told that
prophecy to rira and rira mentioned that
prophecy to Damon and donon was really
angry because he didn't know it so yeah
I agree I think that if jeris knew about
the prophecy we would have seen rira
tell jeris about the prophecy it seems
really important and maybe he'll learn
something about the white walkers when
he goes to Winterfell and talks to Craig
and Stark
yeah yeah yeah um we saw cra's
predecessor uh Brion Stark the previous
Lord of Winterfell um while viseris was
telling R about the prophecy uh in
season 1 so so yeah they definitely are
starting to bring the Starks and the
north into this in a way that's
connected to the prophecy so yeah I mean
jeris may be involved in that and I mean
you know obviously you know the idea
seems to be that each the tarian king
passes this prophecy down to their
successor uh to keep the that knowledge
alive so it would make sense for rer to
tell Jace at some point about that
prophecy but and there's Al also the
question of like when was that knowledge
lost because we know that you know at
least by the time of Game of Thrones no
one apart from like melisandra seems to
be aware of this prophecy so the
question is like you know who knows it
and and when was it lost and the
significance of the Valerian steel
dagger um and like we hear about rhaegar
uncovering old prophecies and
communicating with MAA Amon about uh
these ideas these like lost ancient
stories about prophecy and that's
probably just this story like it's
probably aon's prophecy that he's
uncovering yeah yeah so lots of cool
questions around that DWF antifa says
Hey Globus and Swift offerus um Swift
offerus isn't here right now um you're
talking to Globus and shift offerus yeah
you have me mistaken with my noer do
well um a
half Cousin Al schwift xft X this person
is asking do we think that Jor Mormon
will eventually join the knight's watch
since it was his father's dying
wish again I think this is a case of uh
you know the George gardening his plants
um he's planted that seed like it makes
complete sense that Jr Mormont would say
in his dying breath hey can you please
make sure my son like redeems himself in
some regard cuz he's such a
disappointment such a shame Upon Our
House's Legacy um that doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to happen it
just means that like it's going to carry
some weight going into the future of
jorah's story yeah I agree like just as
much as they could have Jorah join the
Nights Watch in the end they could have
Jorah die or leave and then you know
bemoan the fact that oh I'll never be
able to fulfill my father's dying wish
and they can like lean on the tragedy of
that um it could work either way and and
I mean you know like the whole like will
they need Nights Watch at the end of a
song of watch still exist I'm partial to
the theory that Tyrion will be the last
Lord Commander yeah I really like that
although it conflicts with other like um
equally or even more narratively
resonant ideas about where Tyrion story
is heading I know that you really like
Tyrion being muted um having his tongue
cut outon or someone um but there's a
scene in a Game of Thrones this is a
very early seed that's been planted when
um John says to Tyrion that he needs to
go out beyond the wall to look for
benjin yeah and Tyrion says and who will
look for you yeah and I really like the
idea that it's Tyrion oh
yeah I don't I just think that's super
cute and and like sort of Tyrion being
in charge of you know he's this very
dishonorable fell and that's like the
the nights watches where we send people
who have no place yeah in uh you know
civilized Westeros yeah it's a place for
the outcasts and the re tyan being King
of the outcasts that just makes so much
sense and and also you know the wall is
the place for the punishment for your
crimes and Tyrion has committed horrific
crimes and his punishment for those
crimes is being named hand of the king
yeah and it's and it's so weird that
bran is like yeah Tyrion being hand is
punishment because uh you know all the
[__] he did when he was hand of the king
yeah because Tyrion was such a bad hand
of the king his punishment is to be hand
of the king but but also like you know
like Bran's implication was that oh it's
going to be really it's going to be
really difficult being my hand of the
king and that's why it's uh and that's
why it's a punishment that sounds like
the cushiest job in the world well we
see how cushy it is at the end of the
series when Tyrion is sitting there
joking about like donkeys and Honeycombs
with his buddy Braun and it's like
really like this is what the situation
is this is punishment for for sending
Daenerys down over War exploded the city
yeah tyrian AR makes no sense um in
season 8 to me so um yeah I I I like
that idea it's all right I like that
idea of Tyrion uh going to the wall
that's beit difficult if he's also a
mute though so I don't
know thanks for the Super Chat from
Mattis who says so great to catch you
guys live greetings from Germany thanks
for staying up thank you endera and
Haley who says so it seems like they've
cut day out of the show oh we didn't
talk about this let's talk about drron
who's Dron Dron Targaryen is Allis and
viseris youngest child he's the fourth
child of them it goes Aon Helena a and
Daron um and he doesn't show up in House
of the dragon and he hasn't appeared in
this teaser or any promotional material
and there are rumors on Dragon Twitter
that he's not in season to at all it
would be weird if he was not included
because he's there that's him yeah in
this so clear and so easy to follow
diagram at the start of each episode uh
this this circle that represents Allison
has four Bloodlines coming from it which
represents four children and that's V's
bloodline running into hers from off
screen there so it should be Aon and
Helena and amond and dayon um so we've
been told by the show's creators that
dayon is canonically hanging out in
Oldtown said that too y yeah so so he's
around um yeah there are rumors that
he's not being included in this season
which we think would be weird don't we
yeah I could like it could work but it
doesn't I don't like it like like why
include him in the diagram at all if
he's not going to turn up in season 2 um
so yeah look we'll we'll see what
happens we'll see what happens um I I
think there's not a whole lot to say
about him like he's he's being the cup
Bearer for Lord high tower and he uh he
has a dragon I don't think it's a
spoiler to say that he has a dragon um
no no he's a tarian prince called Tarion
the blue Queen who's supposedly really
sexy and and cool and
blue yes uh and so that's about as much
as we can say about Tarion yeah
um it's just strange that like he's in
the opening credits but he's never
mentioned he's not even mentioned I I
think that you know he spent half of the
show with his
family it does make sense that they
might want to cut some characters and
simplify things a bit because like a lot
of casual viewers are already totally
overwhelmed by the number of characters
and the relationships think that's due
to the time skipping which is not going
to be a factor in the show going forward
true yeah there's there's going to be
less of that and the show's been making
new stuff like left and right so I don't
know reducing what's in the book already
it's s such like a small story I don't
know doesn't really make sense to me
yeah yeah I agree I I I tend to think
and hope Dron will
appear um Darth sfus would like to see
some r n alicent events Callum Arnold
says will the story end this season or
will we get season 3 uh yeah they're
planning to make more seasons last I
heard they're thinking like four or five
seasons even I four makes sense for this
show just like in my concept of how the
show can be paced out especially with
like the shorter season eight episode
season um I don't see it it depends on
where they want to cut the story off
because Fire Fire and Blood the book
extends you know to a certain point and
they don't necessarily have to tell that
part of the story I think they should I
think it'll be good if they did but it
it's a bit of a
weird ending in this in the book because
you know it's the first part of the
Targaryen history yeah there's hundreds
of years of history of which this story
is just one part and it's interesting to
see where they will end it because they
could continue and continue and there's
been speculation about this could become
like an anthology series of House of the
Dragon yeah like they could they could
Simpsons yeah um please maybe not like
The
Simpsons
hey it's not that bad I was watching
season 20 of The Simpsons the other day
and you know what it's not that bad
personally I I just like the first eight
seasons yeah fair enough it it is the
best I won't argue with that yeah um so
yeah I mean George Martin in an
interview did recently mentioned that he
and the showrunners are uh planning and
working on season 3
um so yeah it it seems as though this
will continue hopefully the turbulent
business uh happenings uh in the uh
networks and streamers recently is not
going to disrupt um this show and the
others because it is one of the more
expensive shows to make I'd imagine so
hopefully it'll continue vote with your
wallet thank you Enda who says I am not
watching the screen during this I'm just
listening to your fine audio description
that's a shame put a lot of work into
this visuals thank you faretti who says
I find it very interesting that in the
marketing material they focus on rira
versus Allison and not aegon makes me
appreciate how great of a character
Allison is in the Show versus books even
more yeah the the the show has made this
story they've sort of centered this
story on um Allison and reier more than
the books are like I I think yeah I
think the books do focus a little little
more on aegon and his agency um but but
I think that they've done well to like
explore this relationship and how it
changes and to make it like the
emotional heart of the story um I think
they've both done a great job acting
both their adult counterparts and their
younger um and they've certainly
deepened the relationship I think
they've done a good job with it yep yeah
in the book Allison's just re's evil
stepmother both rer and Allison are more
evil in the books I would say yes
um and maybe this will maybe the show
will see their characters descend into
that same sort of character the behavior
as it goes on yeah it'll be interesting
to see if they keep both of these
characters like quite well-intentioned
and and Noble um and
complex um or if they will start to Veer
into violence and Madness well judging
from the last shot of season
1 I don't see it I don't see reneer
remaining uh poised and
restrained yeah I mean like it's a good
comparison to Daenerys in Game of
Thrones season 8 right because like a
lot of people hated how daena suddenly
turned evil and murdered thousands of
civilians we we didn't feel like we
really got the journey that led her to
that point whereas I think House of the
Dragon is doing a really good job of of
showing how rira has started out having
really good intentions and has had all
these horrible things happen and has
been put in these impossible political
situ
so like you know if it is that they want
to explore like a darker side to her I
think it would make sense in a way that
Daenerys did not make as much sense in
the TV
show yep thank you Mitchell lenius who
says hi schwift lock and Dr G we've seen
Dragon on Dragon action but we'll be see
Dragon on Dragon
action brackets Dragon sex brackets oh
thanks for elaborating than so much for
I didn't what you meant um well it
depends on if Silver Wings up for it I
don't know if Dragons do have
sex because there's all this uh like I
mean you joke mellane we take Dragon sex
very seriously here at on Al shift X um
there's all this speculation in the
books about like dragon's gender and sex
and whether they even have a gender or
sex like some clever characters argue
that dragons uh change their sex they
they Flicker and are as changeable as
flame and so they can be male or female
depending on what's required and it's
not even clear like which ones can lay
eggs or like I don't think there's any
mention of dragons having sex in the
books so mention of them like mating and
coupling but like like no one's ever
like and then I saw this one's you know
Rod go into this
On's I I mean for an author who loves
describing sex as much as George Martin
does it's weird that there's been no
mention of dragons having s i I mean
like yeah I mean there there are some
hints I suppose of dragons like
literally into breeding with valyrians
and tarians but it's but nothing nothing
like specific so I mean yeah I I don't
know if dragons have sex maybe they just
lay eggs maybe they just my toast I
don't know maybe we'll find out maybe
dragons are just clones of other dragons
thank you for the Super Chat from wisdom
who says Shifty and
glue love you guys so much almost not in
a parasocial way that's cool thank you
for the black queen video glid us all
good Shifty thank you for keeping your
evil TN in line someone's got to do it I
do my best snazzy puke says is there
another time skip this season there's a
shot of Damon in armor where his hair
looks longer it's the shot where he's
walking not sitting at the table
interesting
note do you know the shot that is being
brought into a question here I'll see if
I can bring it up my um assumption was
that we're carrying on like basically
immediately from episode 10 of House of
the Dragon
I think his hair has always been that
length hasn't it yeah I think so maybe
it's just like not as tied up here or
maybe it's later in the season you know
days weeks months can pass in the season
but there's not going to be any like and
now it's three years later in this
season yeah we don't expect any big time
skips but yeah I mean certainly there
could be yeah hair growing a bit longer
thanks for the Super Chat from Jack who
says been binging both your old live
streams recently and it's so amazing to
see one live love you
thanks for showing up Mikey fake name
says looking forward to the real Jon
Snow vid Mr shift I am to would you
consider doing similar videos for
Stannis barathan and Theon Greyjoy yeah
I mean I think those are good Pi like
Stannis and Theon are both characters
who have a lot of layers um especially
Stannis like Stannis was not adapted
well in the Game of Thrones TV show Done
Dirty yeah he's got a lot more going on
in the books which would be really
interesting interesting to explore um
Theon was acted so well by Alfie Allen
um but again there's there's even more
depth I think in the books so um yeah it
would be great to make big video
character analyses comparisons about
those characters uh I think that after
the real Jon Snow I'd like to do some
other smaller videos about the north
smaller than 2 hours believe it or not
you know how um at the end of H bomber
guy's most recent video of the 90minut
diet tribe about Tommy tallarico he said
and now I'd like to do some smaller
projects yes that was a year ago yes
he's about to release like a 3-hour
video on something yeah I've I've never
intended to make giant long videos it
just sort of happen so yeah I yeah I
don't know exactly what the plan is um I
I I think that I mean after having done
the real Tyrion and the real JN it would
make some sense to do the real Daenerys
as the other super major Central
character that does make sense yeah um
so I think that uh we'll put it to a
patreon vote at at some point to choose
which character to do next um but for
the mo but for the moment yeah I mean I
think there's a lot of other characters
in the North like like Manz and melandro
and uh you know some other characters
who I've researched incidentally for the
real Jon Snow video where it should be
pretty straightforward to do some quick
videos about them so so yeah we'll see
what happens the real Great John umber
hell yeah thank you Blanco smoke who
says just want to say thanks for all the
great
content over time thank you and who says
who would win in a war house Taran or
house
harcan well you feel this one yeah I'll
uh I'll take this one uh well house har
Conan um has giant
spaceships um yeah but the dragons but
the tarians have dragons I don't know
how the dragons cope with the vacuum of
space um I feel like if the tarians
tried to attack the hakin with Dragons
uh the baron Vladimir hinan would simply
eat them maybe dragons are aliens who
don't need to breathe
maybe dragons are sandworms I mean they
play the same kind of role you know as
these like natural forces of Destruction
that men fool themselves into thinking
they can control yeah and in the later
June books there is a character that can
control sand worms so that's a whole
thing but you know maybe will encounter
a Targaryen who truly can control their
dragons well yeah I mean that's one of
the one of the fun things that hot D is
exploring that isn't so much in the
books is the idea of like to what extent
do tarians truly control their dragons
because Amon did not want vagar to kill
Luke no vagar no no no no but it
happened and you know viseris is saying
that dragons are a force that cannot be
controlled and should not have been
meddled with so so yeah it'll be
interesting to see how they explore that
more but you know the the second Dune
movie is coming out in March and I would
like to make videos about it there's I
mean there's a bunch of Dune videos I
want to make like the philosophy of June
and the top fighters of June and there's
a bunch of little things that are um
half done and mostly done I think oberin
should should be number one oh oh oh
really is that is that what you
think I get these outraged comments on
uh on my uh top fighters in westest
videos all the time and my goodness are
they letting me have it about their
opinions about the top 10 my goodness
thank you ROM who says thank you for all
the content from YouTube gimbus covers
have actually got me super into Billy
Joel recently never heard of him excited
to see what you guys have coming GL
glidus makes uh original music and
covers uh as well for a lot of his
videos released my uh full cover of
Africa by Toto just yesterday yeah so
you can check that out on gladus side
Channel thanks for the Super Chat from
beggi who says Golden Dragon banners
beside the Iron Throne instead of the
green ones Otto had at the end of last
season plus Kristen with the hand chain
chances Egon fires Otto this season
seemed pretty high yeah yeah well
Kristen's hand chain do does seem to
suggest that Kristen and becomes hand of
the king is what is suggested by that
shot so maybe Aon becomes upset with the
way Otto wants to run things we will
have to see but I mean Otto is very
important because he is a Scion of house
high tower which is you know probably
the third most rich and Powerful house
in Westeros and a key Ally of um of
aegon and Allison and the greens so you
don't want to piss off aotto too
much thanks for the Super Chat from t
who says I spent my Halloween excitedly
awaiting the promised cannibalism stream
to see Zero notifications how am I
supposed to know who tastes good now I
don't know if anyone promised something
like that to happen at that time the
stream that was promised yeah I think
you might be referring to the alt
schwift X
awardwinning
world-renowned stream of uh series of
live streams about the food descriptions
in A Song of Ice and Fire yeah do you
think schwift and GL will finish that
series it wouldn't be in character for
us to do
that yeah well look we'll have to see
what they're doing we'll have to see
yeah thank you alt shift of Mia who says
greetings father I bring fell Tidings
old shift of Mia the younger has taken
ill please take this small offering and
send the healers
soon uh well milk of the puppy is
expensive um I'll see what I can do um
but uh you know prayer does
wonders God works in mysterious ways
thank you Pikachu Ferrari and thank you
Lord mud what a name who says greetings
fellow Lords I'd like to inquire as to
your favorite extinct houses of A Song
of Ice and
Fire wink wink who were your top picks
oh jeez extinct
houses um I really like the justments of
the reach of the riverlands what's good
about the adjustments I don't know it's
just like this cool hearkening back to a
a per period in time where some guys
like managed to unite the riverlands
truly yeah and it's something I think
like sort of on the nose um symbolic
it's so like over the top like I'm a
good person I am a just man yeah and the
just noble man is extinct yeah and they
yeah it's they all died terribly it's
like it's like Arthur DNE you know it's
like the noble idealized fantasy good
guy is is a species that has died out in
modern Westeros um well Barrison seli is
still alive but his legacy is a bit
murky in a way that none of the
characters really like to discuss which
is the other theme which is that even
the characters who are idealized the
more Stark Barrison SEL the more you
examine them the more you find that
things are complicated and sometimes the
people who seemed perfect were not so
perfect and you know history is always
more complicated and that's one of the
fun meta themes of Hot D is that you
know Hot D was first conceived as this
you know side note in A Song of Ice and
Fire that was quite straightforward but
then you know the more that George
expanded the story The more layers and
complexity he found in his own
characters as he was inventing them and
now Ryan and the showrunners of H are
inventing their own layers and finding
their own depths it's sort of this
fractal thing where the deeper you look
the more you find every time turns out
that uh very few things are actually
simple um I'm also partial to the gray
ions I just think that's a cool name and
they did a cool thing yeah do you think
the ions have anything to do with
grayscale in the iron Islands do you
mess with the uh lepers in Iron Islands
theories and the gray King had gray
scale are you into all that uh I haven't
thought too much about that honestly
yeah there's some interesting theories
about the ironborn um oh yeah they're
they're a they're a fishy Bunch yeah and
you know like the mythology sort of
lowkey mentions and you know and by the
way we had this Immortal King who stole
fire from the gods by the and like
sacrificed a demon wewood and a dragon
and it's like huh that sounds like it
might be
significant any moving on to the next
king thank you beauty and Bailey who
says how do you think the story will
change or expand in respect to Allison
and Reiner's relationship compared to
the
books yeah I mean they're on opposite
sides of the war now I don't know how
many opportunities they're going to have
to talk
um you know I mean I guess I mean we've
seen rir flying around on a dragon like
going to Storm's end um and apparently
she said she would return to King's
Landing on Dragon back and apparently
flying um apparently flying in what
looks like a battle with amond is what
it looks like in the trailer so uh yeah
I mean maybe if rer is flying around
some more there'll be more opportunities
for her to get back with Allison and to
try and figure things out I mean you
know that there sort of there's a sense
of tragic miscommunication because
you know rera thought that uh she and
Allison had reconciled because you know
at that dinner um they were holding
hands again and they were being close
and you know there was a sense of
agreement so that's why it was shocking
when Allison crowned aegon um if they
could talk then Allison could say hey
reira the reason why I crowned aegon is
that I is that my husband of aera said
that he wants aegon to be the king and
then R's like oh no what a tragic
misunderstanding what he really
meant yeah which you know not like that
conversation could possibly solve
everything but you know they could at
least understand each other and rira
could at least realize that oh okay
Allison has actual reasons she wasn't
just lying to my face in episode8 she W
she actually that was real but of course
you know by the time they have that
conversation there's probably already
been battles and it's already too far to
turn back and you know I think that's
one of the tragic undercurrents um and
you know something else theyve talked
about in the show is the idea that there
was some kind of like intimacy some
almost like romantic love between
Allison and riro really early on oh this
girl is in love with that girl like no
question yeah and you know the idea of
like is it is is that something that
could in some way be recaptured um
pictured two platonic friends being
platonic but they also have changed so
much you know so yeah I'll be I'll be
really interested to see how it develops
and of course you know what what more
horrible things will they each do as
this war continues and you know yeah be
interesting to see uh oh um what do you
think about rain going into battle
rather than ruling from I'm interested
to see how they justify that
decision yeah it's going to have to be
addressed if it's not address it's just
a dumb idea yeah um and also you
mentioned that like yeah reira in the
books like gets more overweight and
that's like used against her as like
she's not as appealing unfit to rule got
a bit fat yeah like because this is a
sex of society like women who are hot
get a lot more support than women who
are not remember when Robert Baratheon
became incredibly fat exactly and no one
cares and and viseris King viseris in
the books get fat gets fat no one cares
well he's he's jolly and plump yes uh
whereas when a woman gets plump it's
like ah she's she's IL legitimate cast
her down so um so yeah I mean I don't
know if that's something that they're
going to do in the show but uh the show
definitely is interested in exploring
like sexism and patriarchy so it's also
interested in having hot actors yeah
yeah I mean it is funny that like the
show wants to explore sexism but God
forbid they ever have anyone on the
screen who's anything less than a nine
you know like that's one of the
paradoxes of Hollywood is that like you
know let let's let's let's uh do
representation tell a story about this
ugly duckling let's do representation
but not of anyone who's anything less
than a super model you know um so there
are certainly paradoxes in our Hollywood
handles that stuff that said I I I'm of
the mind that all of that discussion of
Rene's growing weight in the book was
you know political oh yeah in nature
yeah yeah yeah because the book is all
about like the people writing the
history are politically motivated and so
when they're trying to make people seem
good or bad they they're biased in how
they write comments from male historians
about the you know exact nature of
women's bodies are like LED all
throughout the book yeah and it's all
it's all nonsense yeah yeah so so so
creating a canonical version of that
they've got a lot of latitude in the
show to um change stuff uh Lord Bumpus
says something to Glide down n but shift
up for premiere of Hot D to s that's
quite beautiful Bumpus I don't
understand it but I like your little
poem to print it and frame it on the
fridge Jennifer says who's alt shift X
and what has he done with shwifty
schwifty has been detained uh for the
safety of all you know that EP that um
isn't an episode or is it just a
Treehouse of Horror segment you know
Bart's twin
Hugo yeah no that that I yeah I've got a
spacious comfortable attic for for
schwift to frolic in so don't worry
thank you Bane's basement who says so
glim Bon
please inform his lordship that the
ancestral seat of schift Mark is now
under attack by the scari Savages of
swiftwood Hall yeah they'll figure it
out do you think the scari are as Savage
as we are told no I really like the idea
that the scosi which is like a island
off the North like I like the idea that
they're like hardcore Northern
worshippers who still sacrific the trees
and like in the books rickon Stark is on
scaros hanging out with unicorns and his
Dire Wolf and I like the idea that they
might sort of radicalize him into a
badass old God skin changer Cool D there
were a few um like Northern old gods
coded badass children in Fire and Blood
who like that could like hearken back to
yeah yeah as we said it would be great
to see a bit more of the north um in
this show the real North and it looks
like they want to do that yeah um thank
you my dad after a
bath he says will you two beautiful boys
do Telltale got episode
2 um well this is in reference to um
what alt swiftex and I did on his
channel alt Swift X
gaming um we played one episode of The
Game of Thrones Telltale Game which was
released in like 2015 or
something um and then we didn't do it
again because it was really annoying
streaming a game like that and still
trying to talk over well from from what
I saw it it looked as though it's quite
difficult to commentate over a game
that's about conversations and and also
about choices in those conversations
that you have to pay attention to it was
like I'm sure it was fun for the
audience but it was
frustrating yeah well you know for all I
know there could be uh new alt trift X
gaming streams sometime soon so who
knows who knows who knows subscribe to
that channel thank you Lal La Loopsy who
says don't know what's going on but I
just caught a stream is fantasy Haven
beat you to it yeah well I slept in
today thank you Marcus who says Bas and
gler pilled true thank you will who says
Dr schift and Mr Glide hope you're doing
well kind of hoping we get to see the
cannibal at some point I think that' be
great as well I think uh I think we ju
might just see the cannibal H have has
the cannibal been mentioned though in
this TV yes yeah yeah because um Damon
mentions the three Untamed dragons that
make their layers in the dragon Mont or
on Dragon Stone this is the uh official
art by Renee agnar of uh cannibal grey
ghost and sheep stealer and yeah
cannibal is the fun friendly dragon so
badass who uh lives on Dragon stone is a
wild Untamed dragon and it likes to eat
baby dragons and other dragons uh for
the protein I suppose there's also the
elusive gray ghost who's rarely seen and
there's also sheep stealer who likes to
steal sheep um so who could take control
of these dragons is an important
question thank you Chef P Panther foot
that's a great name yeah he says finally
got to catch you guys live you're
awesome thank you thank you wish I
thought of Chef Panther foot before
gliders thank you oh you wouldn't
believe how many times I've I've dreamed
of uh coming up with a name that's
easier to spell than Al shift x uh thank
you Nala who says what are your
expectations from aegon II did you like
his coronation scene in episode 9 I got
chills with his teary eyed walk with
that epic soundtrack it is indeed an
epic soundtrack and I also really
enjoyed the coronation scene it's a bit
muddled by what happened at the end but
still pretty good scene like like that
the this bit it's just epic yeah I mean
I I think we already discussed how like
you know it it means something to Aon
that he's actually getting approval and
love um from the common people and I I
want wonder if he might become less of
an awful person and might actually try
to do the right thing by the common
people um and I think you know like
we've compared it before to there's that
moment where
Joffrey uh discovers the joy of the
Common People season 3 episode something
or
other yeah that that one there and
Cersei is in the back here going like uh
I don't know about this yeah hang on a
moment how dare he find approval in
other people yeah exactly my son son is
getting emotional security from someone
other than me I'm losing my Monopoly on
emotional control of my child yeah it's
uh it's definitely a dynamic that is
evoked by the Allison Aon relationship
so um so yeah I'm really fascinated like
you know that aegon could have an
opportunity to make policies and to make
decisions about who his advisers are and
who his hand of the king is and to make
decisions about you know maybe he could
decide that hey maybe peace with uh r
good idea after all there's infinite
possibilities um but we've also seen
that you know at least previously aegon
has shown little interest in anything
other than drinking and womanizing and
watching his bastard children fight in
pits it's a niche hobby I'll Grant I'm
sure there's a subreddit for it um so
yeah I I'm fascinated to see what
happens thank you Violet who says in
honor of the camp Silver Creek staff
dragon show nerd Club Moose salad and
bearg the doy says I hated Reiner's
silence at the end of season 1 she
should have screamed you got to be risen
me to express her
anguish I'm not sure I agree with that I
I think the decision to have a stare at
me
personally uh was great I think it was
implied yeah the screaming about the
Risen was implied um I I think that it
worked really well as a cliffhanger and
I think I think whether we like it or
not it works as a call back to
Daenerys um and her grumpy face in
season 8 episode 4 um which I I think
it's so funny when Amelia Clark pretends
to be an angry person it's just she's
got such a lovely um just
like she's got a nice face have you seen
Amilia Clark in that romcom with the
with the be socks no oh it's just like
Amilia clar at her most sort of bubbly
and fun and it's just a hilarious
comparison to daen area yeah thanks for
the Super Chat from Simco who says I was
about to go to sleep but going to catch
the latest shler and glimmer true thank
you Charlie who says turned up love you
also love poor
Helena uh Raven says horse's name that
Cole is riding is Tyreek Lannister Ty
Lan is a time traveling horse shifter
glidus did you see that new I say new
did you see that
2003 draft outline of a fe of crows SL A
Dance with Dragons I did written by
George R in 2003 and recently leaked to
someone who posted it on
Reddit what what did it say on that
outline the very first note in that
outline Under The Heading Daenerys was
pretend it is a horse
M and like I didn't ask for Apollo to
give me the gift of Prophecy but glidus
has been saying for
years that uh Tyreek Lannister um the
mystery of Tyreek Lannister is that he
actually in fact is a horse because the
book says that Tyreek Lannister is it
was the last seen a horse last seen a
horse so um so look you clearly can see
the future and George clearly agrees um
Daenerys is pretending to be a horse or
Ty yeah look we'll figure it out we'll
make a video it's all the same horse
thank you Bane's basement who says
apparently Ryan Condell brought Hayden
Christensen for season 2 to teach the
rosb how to burn aive no shot
thank you Simco who says just realized
it's actually Al shift X can't believe
you're cheating on shwifty with these
mortal enemy gliders we've got a deal
sort of that don't worry I'm going to
stab shift after the stream don't worry
oh my
God betrayal treachery at two at two
glutes GL thank you Ginger who says
first live I've caught love your guys
videos thank you uh lots lots of
speculation about schwift uh schwift hey
you leave our personal relationship to
us okay thank you Olivia Williams who
says many Super Chat thank you Shane who
says at one point John talks about how
he would have
be with EET in the godswood meaning in
front of bran why is George so weird
with siblings okay so what Shane is
referring to is that um John in his
relationship with eager he fantasizes
about what if I could take eaget home
with eggs and have be eggs he he
imagines making love to his girlf friend
in his home and in the backyard I think
that's in front of his dad's big tree in
the backyard and I think that's quite
lovely um at this time Jon does not know
that his brother brand is a psychic tree
Wizard who can see through the eyes of
trees so I don't think that's meant to
be weird I what I do think is meant to
be weird is that John repeatedly thinks
that yret reminds him of Aya and then he
in the same paragraph feels sexually
attracted to jret and imagines what she
looks like under her clothes so given
that there was a love triangle planned
in a 199 something outline of fire um
there was an original plan for JN and
Aya to have a sexual relationship in uh
early outlines of the story so uh if
you're looking for weird incest
undertones in Jon's relationship with
uret there you go correct me if I'm
wrong wasn't the third point of that
triangle Tyrion yeah yep yep yep yep
nice work George yep yep yep yeah it's
amazing how many like catastrophically
bad story decisions George like
sidestepped you know like Jamie being
this murderous um guy who goes around
killing everyone in line to the throne
so that he can user the throne like just
Jamie Lannister just couldn't do that
one of the this doesn't make sense
anymore one of the interesting things so
like I I'm working on a video about Jon
Snow in the books and one of the
interesting never mentioned this I know
one of the interesting things about John
in the show compared to the books is
that a lot of the things that the show
added to the story a lot of the things
that the show did that weren't in the
books are things that George mtin did at
one time plan to include in the books
but he decided not to but then the show
decided to do it so an example of that
is um the mutineers at Cris keep KL fuk
and Tanner and all those Fells Legend of
chinali um in the TV show JN goes and
kills car tener um in the uh books that
does not happen but apparently in an
early draft of the books George did
intend for JN to go and do that so it
seems as though uh the show Runners were
like oh we'll do this thing that George
planned George must have told them that
oh I was planning on doing this so why
don't you guys do that but I think that
funnily enough George most of the things
that George cut out of the story he cut
out for really good reasons I think that
I think it was good that George removed
that um
and I think it was one of the more lame
things that happened in the show there's
there's no like morality as early as
season 4 like when things were still
pretty solid it was one of the weirder
things that happened yeah yeah and it
didn't really add much to the character
it gave John something to do yeah be
because they made this weird timeline
accident where where JN in season 3 gets
ahead of all of the other characters in
terms of his story AR that's right he
gets he gets back to Castle black at the
end of season 3 with like a full season
before the battle happens which is like
a few chapters later in the book exactly
yeah all the story lines were desynced
so they added this mut year plotline to
get it back into sync I mean maybe just
like twiddles his thumbs for a season
yeah it's very weird and also like in
the TV show Jon Snow goes to hard home
and he fights a white walker and he
saves the wild links uh that also does
not happen in the books George
definitely thought about putting it in
yes because I mean in that uh 2003 draft
outline that we just mentioned
it says that John's Arc will end at hard
home mhm and this is for um the fourth
book yeah which eventually got split
into two books feast and dance um it's
all so complicated but the point is that
as far as I can discern based on the
information that's leaked out um it
seems like a lot of the weird stuff that
happens to join in the show was
originally planned to be included in the
books but George changed his mind so
just kind of interesting just kind of
interesting to me interesting thank you
Ginger who says have you guys discussed
the identity of the Dragon across from
Raina we think it's probably sea smoke
dreamfire is an interesting thought it
could be dreamfire I guess we we in my
head dreamfire should be like pretty big
because she's very old yeah dreamfire is
one of the older dragons um and I think
she's the second oldest Dragon aside
from cannibal cuz we don't know exactly
how old the cannibal is but it's like
Vega dreamfire then
veror yeah yeah yeah so yeah so
dreamfire should be a big lad or a big
last then when we see her in episode six
uh she's not that big she doesn't seem
that big it's kind of tough to tell
under the dragon pit yeah well we don't
even know for sure if that is dream fire
do
we I guess it could have been
Sunfire but like we cut directly to
Helena is uh is
this uh where is's the drag is it
episode 6 yeah it is how dare you
question
me you are very up to date on this um
but yeah no yeah we yeah yeah this one
yeah we do Glimpse this dragon that Amon
sees but I mean the lighting you can't
tell what color it is because of the
lighting I mean it looks kind of red
actually m i speculated that because it
has the same sort of design as droon
Regal and viserion that it is dreamfire
who is speculated to be their mother I
it's it's a long bow Ryan Condell puts a
lot of attention into those details but
does he put that much attention to the
details I don't know honestly he could
has he come I really think he could has
he come up with a dragon family tree I
hope so Abs if any showrunner of any
show would have well the point is that
we we don't have any 100% confirmed
sightings of dreamfire yeah so it's
really hard to tell uh which one's dream
fire if any um thank you hoy who says
will we ever get Fire and Blood Abridged
oh man what an idea yeah well I mean Al
shrift X has spent about um 17 years uh
doing a chapter by chapter live stream
analysis a third of the way through a
Clash of Kings yeah so I look I I mean
maybe when schwift finishes A Song of
Ice and Fire shrift will then move on to
Duncan egg and Fire and Blood um it
might take a while at the current Pace
but um you know who knows who knows
thank you for the Super Chat from band
ra bandra he says the good Queen was so
wroth with sir lucamore the Lusty for
dishonoring the king's God because he
also Dishonored his secret relationship
with her and their secret children Balon
and Alysa how dare you slander the good
Queen alisin in my presence so the good
Queen alisin uh was Joe's wife yes King
Jara starian who we saw in the uh
flashback in episode one of House of the
Dragon was married to good Queen alisin
lucamore the Lusty was a King's Guard
who had a bunch of kids and you're not
supposed to do that as a King's Guard
just by the by it's considered a no no
and uh as punishment Luca was uh he was
gilded wasn't he y sent to the wall yep
so does bandra reckoned that good Queen
alisin was having a secret affair with
the king's
God do you believe it why why can't we
let one person be good why can't why
can't one person in this franchise just
have been good well cuz just Man is
dead cuz the Danes are dead I I mean I
mean George has already done this like
like
um yeah this is exactly nerys a on the
Dragon Knight had a relationship
possibly with neres the wife of King
aegon I four it is alleged and heavily
believed that uh their son Daron is
actually a bastard with Aon yeah so I
mean you know it's it's something that
George has done before and will do again
if he's not stopped so uh look it
wouldn't shock us but there isn't a lot
of evidence either way in Fire and Blood
I don't I would like to believe that no
yeah thank you Andre who says House of
the Dragon season 2 trailer episode 10
Bliss incoming you two collabing life is
good we we're collabing for the first
time just a correction yeah I've never
met glus
before no idea who this man is thank you
D Brian haa who says what do you guys
think aegon II would put in in his wheat
bcks well Aon 2 is like
a lost full
um uh bourbon put bourbon in his Li yeah
I could see it yeah look it's like an
Archer sort of move I mean this this is
the kind of kid who who masturbates out
a window like he he's a pleasure Seeker
so yeah I mean bourbon Smarties like you
know whatever you can imagine uh Coco
puffs anything and and then he take the
wheat picks
out eat around the wheat picks yeah
thank you Jordan says where is Sunfire I
know I
know show me Sunfire damn it so Sunfire
is the dragon of aegon II uh and Sunfire
in the books is called the Golden
because he's the most beautiful
magnificent dragon ever uh but sadly
we've not seen uh him looking
magnificent in the show there was this
brief for 4 seconds I mean you can see
him for 4 seconds he's like pixelated in
the background yeah I I would have
preferred they just didn't show us
Sunfire at all until we can see Sunfire
looking better but I mean I I guess they
wanted to establish that hey look
there's a bunch more tarian dragons you
know they honestly this shot it's an
Easter egg really and we've just been
looking at it for a year normal people
are like oh there a dragon in the
background cuz he is meant to have the
like pink highlights as well as the as
the main e streaks the E girl streaks so
um so yeah look I I expect I mean surely
what they're going to do is give us a
nice dramatic fun introduction of
Sunfire early the same way we got a cool
introduction to veror yeah yeah yeah I
think we will get get a moment of that
and and you know it's it's like I I I
enjoy the
Injustice that the Monstrous depraved
Egon II has this beautiful
Dragon uh and that sort of connects with
the theme with a lot of the greens in
Hot D about how the greens have this
veneer of being Noble and pure and
faithful and moral but like just beneath
the surface they are as corrupt as
anybody um it's not even beneath the
surface because like the king and queen
a brother or sister well I mean that's
that's fine Taran I mean come the I mean
yeah I mean it complicates their faith
of the seven um entanglement
but rera says that to to Allison when
when Allison attacks her with the knife
she says like you are just pretending to
be Noble and beneath it's just a cloak
of nobility and so I feel like Sunfire
works as like part of that cloak of
nobility for the greens he looks
magnificent he looks beautiful he looks
Regal and yet aegon is a monster I I
feel like that's part of the symbolism
there um so yeah I look forward to
seeing our beautiful golden Sunfire
too fler 236 who says um what's your
favorite David lightbringer
Theory I uh have been reading a bit
about like the ancient myths of Westeros
and that's a topic that YouTuber David
lightbringer has been deep into for a
long time long time um and I do like the
idea that you know all of these myths
about aor High and the great king and
the winged Knight and uh all of and the
blood Zone Emperor and all of those
people might all point to some important
like inciting incidents that happened in
the ancient history of Westeros and you
know some of these stories hint at like
humans stealing power from the gods like
the great king stole fire from the gods
and killed this tree figure called ye um
and aorai killed Nissa nisser and
cracked the moon uh and the Bloodstone
Emperor killed the amethyst empress and
worshiped a black stone and ruled for a
long time and and and I think that if
you sort of synthesize these ideas one
of the interpretations of those myths is
that maybe azorah high this Mythic
figure uh killed a child of the forest
or some kind of weirwood old God's
figure and sort of stole their power
like stole skin changing power and that
skin changing power might be what
allowed the first dragon Riders to
control their dragons cuz it seems like
a similar kind of magic and that crime
that original sin of of stealing that
power from the trees and from the
children of the forest might have been
what led to the creation of the White
Walkers and the imbalance of the seasons
and that might be the crime that has to
be restored and fixed and atoned for in
order to save the world from the white
walkers restore the seasons to normal
well how does that sort of thing get
atoned what's the how do you repair that
Rift yeah well I mean I don't want to
give away everything that I'm going to
say in the real Jon Snow video that's
coming up um but really you know but but
certainly David lightbringer has talked
about um you know the idea of burning a
weirwood tree and sort of symbolically
giving the fire back to the tree or you
know Daenerys or John having to die and
to give their power back to the tree or
something like that um and and the idea
that that inciting incident might have
been a human having sex with a child of
the forest um an adult child of the
forest terminology gets complicated um
but you know the idea of that something
like that teenagers of the forest
running
around twins of the
forest yeah so something like that I I
think that David lightbringer is is
barking up the correct trees um in in
some of those areas I mean I I haven't
seen um a a fraction of of David
lightbringer he's a very prolific worker
yeah a lot of long essays a lot of big
live streams um and some of them are
really great and um I invite you to
check them out um but yeah there's lots
of lots of great deep theories kicking
around in the fandom for a long time and
uh yeah it's cool to check him
out thank you thank you for the Super
Chat from gfus Pike who says father
schwi Hill and quen flowers have entered
the drowned Gods watery Halls they were
taken in the rear by the crowy whilst
fleeing the shields I've sent word to
the late Lord Haven begging Aid glyph us
all right sounds like you got this
sorted out then I I'd love to read like
a Wiki summary yeah someone's got to get
on this cuz I'm going to be honest like
I can't keep I I I can keep track of the
song of I and fire I cannot keep track
of the movements of all of my I want to
see a family tree like how how do
how does glyf this Pike relate exactly
need to construct a subreddit for people
to collaborate and figure all of this
out it's going to turn into like an RP
mush yeah oh my god um it's going to be
a sub mod for the Crusader Kings 3 Game
of Thrones mod gpus I'll pray for you
thank you radnage who says top priority
after Danny returned from her first time
riding drogon should have been to have a
saddle that is true you get off that
thing and like yep we're fixing this
right away can you imagine how
uncomfortable it would be sitting on
those spiky scales oh I don't know her
hair looked fine
so here's the other thing about Daenerys
Daenerys had just spent a year sitting
on a horse saddle yeah she's she spent
most of her time in a saddle yeah how
could she not think hey we should put a
saddle on this
Dragon she I mean she must have known
saddle makers among the dothi saddle
making must have been one of the main
cultural activities of the dothi for
sure right yeah thank you Kaiser who
says what if the reason the dragons got
smaller and died off was due to
inbreeding considering they all from
Three Dragons and it would be a thematic
reflection of the tarian
incest yeah like it's just a too small a
gene pull to support um a lengthy uh
descendant line yeah cuz one of the
details about the dragons is that like
towards a certain point in the history
the dragons started getting small and
misshapen and they didn't Thrive anymore
and the books offer a bunch of different
reasons why that may have happened
um and one reason is that the tarians
started keeping the dragons inside the
dragon pit and they don't made them
weaker and smaller and another theory is
that the maesters may have poisoned the
dragons because they didn't want the
dragons around I'm coming around on the
idea like every time the mases are
accused of some Grand conspiracy to Rob
someone else of their power it's just
nonsense it's just made up well except
except that we see something like that
happen in the prologue of a Clash of
Kings right like yeah in the books maest
creson tries to assassinate melisandra
for political and ideological reasons
partly because he opposes her being a
sorceress yeah right but that is one
maester acting on his personal valtion
right yeah and like sure there might be
some like underlying institutional fear
of magic and that sort of power but I I
think it's just going to be more
complicated in the end than the maesters
wanted the dragons gone and so they
killed them all yeah I yeah I I I don't
think the dance of the Dragons is ever
going to be one thing with one cause um
it'll be boring if they say it was all
the MA's manipulation but I mean hotti
has also leaned in to the um conniving
nature of the maesters and Otto's
connection to the maesters through old
town and so you know it is implied that
Otto is using the maesters to push his
own political agenda um and yeah we see
like isolated incidents like presson
trying to poison melisandra in a song of
there's marwin who accuses his own
institution of all these Grand misdeeds
over the past Millennia yeah yeah yeah
it's um it's quite funny um but but I
think that you know so conspiracy
conspiracies happen um
but George is very focused on individual
characters so he he he's never going to
let individual motivations individual
emotions be erased for the sake of some
kind of conspiracy um so this scene oh
my god oh
yeah yeah let's not even look at season
s there's one acolyte attending to the
entire conclave of arch
me thank you for the Super Chat from
47th light who says this is a bit
strange and wimpy on my part but I'm
being a new mother but being a new
mother I'm concerned about h
perhaps we should address that in some
time yeah so we're not going to discuss
uh major plot spoilers uh in this stream
maybe at the very end we briefly will
but um I mean to talk generally I mean
there's a lot of murder um and assault
and War in this show and in Game of
Thrones um so I guess we've all going to
make decisions about what kind of stuff
we want to see and how to handle it um
and I completely understand this um my
brother watches my videos and he's about
to become a father for the first time
and I'm just like I'm gonna tell him to
stop just for a little
bit uh yeah I mean yeah we we saw Luke
um die in season one and we see reera as
a parent having to deal with that and
the consequences of that and yeah I
don't think there's any shame if you
feel like um child murder is not the
kind of entertainment that you want to
see yeah no judgment from me if that's
um something you want to void yeah I I I
think a media diet um should not only
contain child murder it's not it's not
what everyone needs to see at every time
and that's all right um rich and hung
asks what state of as do we handsome
young Lads come making a lot of
assumptions there well I come from the
southern part of
Austria oh yeah near Ty that's right y I
come from the state of
anation as as do most of us thought that
was the capital of um um yeah no I I
think Geographic ambiguity is our
preferred State isn't it thank you Haley
who says odds of HBO making a prequel
not focused on
TS oh I'm not hopeful yeah I me like
Duncan egg is going to happen but like I
mean one of the main characters is a
Targaryen that they filmed a pilot for a
show called blood moon that was about
the ancient West arosi before the tug
Aran involving ancient Starks and
ancient Lannisters and involving origins
of the white walkers potentially and
like that sounds potentially interesting
maybe also potentially terrible could go
a bunch of different ways I mean you
know there is a lot of interesting
history in that time um it's all
incredibly vague at this point yeah um
so I mean maybe but I mean HBO turned
down that that pilot for a reason
presumably yep
um but I mean you know be before aon's
Conquest there isn't a whole lot of
detailed history to work with really
there's mostly just Legends there's
mostly just history so yeah I mean I
mean there is stuff like you know the
Golden Empire of
ET um that is apparently being developed
but I mean that that we just don't have
any detailed stories or information
about those places really so it's it's
kind of hard to say I mean in theory I
mean you can you can write any you can
write a great story set anywhere you
know um
as long as you got good characters and
good story anything's possible yep so
we'll see what
happens my dad after her bath once again
says think think we'll get Duncan egg
books faster because of the
show
no I think that George has like forced
himself to not work on that stuff until
you know the one everyone wants is done
George Martin said about six or eight
years ago I will not write anything
until I finish the Winds of Winter and
then he wrote two more books um so look
he said that he's going to write like 10
more Duncan egg stories to finish the
tales of Duncan egg um I don't think we
will get them all uh I think unless he
like writes one a
month I I I think just fall out of him I
I think that it could possibly work if
you know George Martin sat down with the
show runner of the dunk and de TV show
and I hope Ryan Condell is in the room
and he just sort of like tells the
outline the basic idea of each dunan egg
story and I I could imagine that in the
right hands like an outline of George's
plans could be turned into a good dunan
egg show um I think that's possible but
I
mean I I am frustrated that they are
starting another TV adaptation of
another unfinished George Martin book
series that's that's how I
feel yeah
and sure maybe the Duncan egg show will
make George focus more on the Duncan egg
books but that'll be at the cost of
George focusing on finishing the Winds
of Winter so you know it's uh but what
if they do an ad an adaptation of the
main Ice and Fire books and that'll make
him focus on those books oh that would
work they should make a TV show of of
Game of Thrones they could call it isn't
it crazy how between Game of Thrones
being greenless and
today
one book has come out
yeah yeah it uh it does not seem as
though the TV shows have helped George
finish the main books
no cat says it's confusing for the
future story to not include Dron yeah
absolutely we agree it's confusing for
the past story because heing the credits
Mike says New Age bomber Guy video what
do they tell you look at that what do
they tell you are we prophets thank you
c ma who says thank you both for getting
me through a very difficult time in my
life I cannot describe how much these
videos have helped me I appreciate you
the Comfort content thank you very much
thanks Cass hope you're doing good glad
we could help yeah thank you Shane who
says thanks to both of you I listened to
all the books from Dave reads A Song of
Ice and Fire and now join the wait for
wins I honestly hate not getting it into
it until now uh I I don't know if you
missed out on much
is Dave Reeds A Song of Ice and Fire is
is that a YouTube channel that reads the
books yeah and that and that is YouTube
somehow stays afloat yes I will never
understand YouTube's copyright policy
yeah no my 80 minute comment that's
heavily edited and transformative of
House of dragon no no no no no that's
that's copyright infringement when when
glidus uses seven consecutive seconds of
footage how did from the TV show he gets
the Susan H but there's other YouTube
channels doing other things that that
are just reading the books yeah which
again like you know more power to you
but um it's a very confusing world we
live in in terms of copyright this is
the life I chose very confusing uh
thanks for the Super Chat from mea re hi
Mera um do what you love CU a pirate is
free you are a pirate thank you guy
Incognito who says love both channels
glidus is a cheeky what does that word
say K and I love it Kint question how do
you chaps think they'll handle sea smoke
Kint yeah I mean we spoke a bit about
sea smoke it it it it is an interesting
difference between the show and the
books that in the CH books it seems that
sees smoke that Lor valerion is dead
whereas in the show Lor valerion is
alive so the question is like will Coke
get a new Rider is it possible for Coke
to get a new Rider while Lor is still
alive uh uh we don't
know um we can't speculate too much
without giving spoilers um maybe we'll
do a spoiler Corner towards the end
thank you Bane's baseman who says do you
think this season's prophecy reference
will be between Jace and kraan should we
enter the spoiler Zone yeah why not all
right I would like to declare a spoiler
Zone um we abandon all hope ye who pass
this threshold yes um so uh
spoiler Zone I mean it's not it's a
mediumsized spoiler it's a mild to
mediumsized spoiler uh that when in the
books when jeris goes to the north and
he meets the Lord of Winterfell craen
star uh there is a is it called a pack
of Ice and Fire yeah when the tarians
and the Starks um make an alliance to
support rera and and that wording is
very evocative of The Song of Ice and
Fire and connects to the prophecy of the
prince that was promised which is uh the
prophecy connected to Aon conquering
Westeros to stop the white walkers Etc
um so it would make a lot of sense if
jce and kraan discussed the prophecy of
the prince that was promised um it is
weird that we have not seen rer tell
Jace about that prophecy so like you
said maybe craan will tell Jace about
the prophecy yeah because the Starks
could know it it might be the thing that
Aon used to convince torren Stark to
yield the north to him in the wars of
Conquest torrin went down without a
fight yeah that's a great Point um in
his famous
artwork and there are some um there are
some sort of suggestions and theories
that the Starks have special knowledge
of the White Walkers and even some kind
of potential deal with you know how the
war went up and and the White Walker
stopped attacking in the first place so
you know it it does make a lot of sense
that there might be a bit of shared
knowledge um which you know adds to the
tragedy of the loss of that knowledge
and the deaths that that happen later on
um so yeah I mean that could make a lot
of sense but I mean the more they talk
about the prophecy stuff the more I just
get confused because it's like the
prophecy stuff in Game of Thrones season
8 didn't matter Aya killed the night
King and Aya did not have anything to do
with the prophecy compared to JN and
Daenerys so it's like it's a bit
puzzling to me the more they emphasize
the prophecy stuff
um because because yeah it just doesn't
connect to the Game of Thrones show so I
don't know what do you think it like
they'd have to rcon or is it like a
postcon because it's going forward oh
God yeah um yeah Arya has no targaryan
blood so far as we know so it just
doesn't really add
up um yeah I think it's definitely
steering towards book Cannon away from
show Cannon but that's like something
that the show can't really explain in
its own text it's like like Jace turns
to the camera and says by the way this
isn't leading to the season 8 you know
just just just so you know yeah House of
the Dragon exists in a really weird like
wobbly Canon Canon limbo where it's sort
of somewhere in between the books and
the show so
um yeah I don't know I I I don't I don't
love the use of the prophecy stuff in
Hot D honestly um but we'll see how it
goes I think they need to be careful
with it thanks for the Super Chat from
Fen who said are we exiting the spoiler
Zone let's just stay there for now all
right well what's the point um well how
about you discuss John dying at hard
home while I alter the visuals to people
asking does that mean joh would have
died at hard home I think this is in
reference to that outline where George
or what you were talking about earlier
where George said that Jon's Arc was
going to end at hard home I think that
could have worked if he had died there
and come back to life um you know as a
result of the battle at hard home but I
guess George decided it was cooler if it
was you know his own brothers who killed
him in a mutiny
um yeah that very much could have been
the case that that's what he envisioned
at some point and then later decided to
not do
that thanks lady stonehart Kimmy G who
says love all three glbo schwifty and
even this one schwift thanks for a great
afternoon needed it today you got it
thank you orelon who says how much do we
need to donate to have schwifty released
from the dungeons I don't think he can
do more food descript streams from down
there you should put like a stream a
donation goal bar on the stream yeah I
look I if you're going to post bail for
schwift it's not going to be cheap I
think his crimes are Beyond forgiving um
Joseph Rizzo says hello glim Bland and
shifting away now that the final Bliss
take is done might be get a be a
Boulders Gate 3 stream the content is
still hot is it do people still care um
I barred myself from playing any of
these hot new titles that came out this
year until I had finished working on the
thing I was supposed to be working on so
I haven't played Starfield or Boulders
gate or any of these what are you doing
over there I'm just blocking out the
thing that says no spoilers okay um yeah
maybe I'll stream it I don't know I I
would like to play Boulders gate at some
point I still haven't played Elden ring
and that was something I said that I
would stream it's got GM involved in it
yeah there there's there's a lot of
games that I'd like to play just finding
the time yeah and sometimes like when I
want to experience a game like that I
don't want to do it before a live studio
audience I want to just do it on my own
yeah yeah I think a lot of YouTubers go
through the thing of oh I like live
streaming I like video games what if I
live stream playing video games suddenly
it became a job yeah it turned something
that is like fun and relaxing into
something that's like draining yeah uh
thank you Canary who says love both of
y'all's videos just wanted to say that
uh I know glidus is an Aquarius what is
old shift X's uh astronomy sign I'm an
Aus yeah I'm an Aus wow no that's just
me trying to sound
cool um do we have more things to say
about this teaser or should we wrap up
this live stream mean we' I'm sure we
could the question is should we yeah um
yeah well we've talked for three hours
about a 90 second should we quickly go
through now that we're in the spoiler
Zone should we talk about what you know
actually will happen yeah all right um
I'm going to put a bit of text on the
screen that says spoiler
Zone um what are some of the spoilers
that we want to talk about
um oh
geez um so I mean one of the things is
like sea smoke right so like spoiler
spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler warning
spoiler warning spoiler warning um oh
God is it Adam or alen Adam Adam valion
claims sea smoke in the books um which
raises this really interesting question
of is Lor still alive um I mean and Adam
by the way is you know said to be the
son of uh Lor valion who is gay which is
odd so a lot of people think that is
actually callus who was the father of
Adam and Allen um and some people even
speculated uh some people speculated
that Adam valion might actually be Lor
yeah I love that idea returning from the
East that's so fun thus explaining how
Adam could claim sea Smoke by simply
being
L but like he finally acquired a fake
mustache but what what is the point of
Faking your own death and becoming
someone else if you are going to inhabit
almost the same role in the same family
in the same W like what now I'm no
longer A's husband you
see it's a hell of a way to break up
with someone we've all we've all tried
have them fake your death for you genius
um so yeah I mean I mean yeah the role
of Adam and I assume they're going to
play it the same way as it's played in
the books with you know them being
calluses and pretending to be Lor and
but I mean I I do like the way because
it would be offensive to rainy if they
were C this as bastards yeah which which
sort of is a Catlin comparison isn't it
like
catlin's uh frustration with you know
Ned claiming John as his bastard and you
know how will Raines feel about uh
corus's bastards Adam and Allen being
around a lot of cat's agitation was that
uh Ned kept his supposed bastard around
yeah which K is clearly hasn't done yeah
well he's certainly not now if he's
bringing Adam and Allen into the fold
yeah um one of the other spoilery things
is that and this this's a minor spoiler
really but that that guy I think is um
the Lord of duskendale Lord darkland
yeah because Kristen Cole is going to do
some smashy smashy in the crown Lance um
and that's going to lead on to that
battle that we've seen um uh spinny
balls uh flying sea smoke uh this uh
spoiler mild spoiler I think is probably
Haren hole right y um because Damon
takes over Haron Hall and there's a
weirwood there we know there are
weirwoods at Haron Hall and I think the
Haren Hall weirwood is going to matter
because Alice Rivers is there and Alice
is this sort of magical mysterious
character who is watching uh might be
connected I mean yeah look if Isaac
Hemstead Wright makes some kind of like
voiceover appearance in this it would
not be terrible honestly I would kind of
like it um and yeah I mean you know mild
spoilers you know Amon does sort of rise
to basically become the king in orbit a
in a gonstead yeah
um we don't really know what this nights
watchy Northern yeah I still don't know
what this is even in the spoiler Zone I
mean I guess the Nights Watch people
could be an opportunity to say hey White
Walkers are scary we we are going to the
Nights Watch because there are white
walkers out there so honly if I'm a like
free folk Chieftain beyond the wall and
I hear that there's a civil war going on
in Westeros and the lord of the north is
pledging his troops to go south that's
the perfect time to attack yeah yeah
that's a great Point um I don't know if
they're going to do that I doubt they
will but could happen just just a mini
war between the wildlings and the and
the Knights watch in the background that
would be fun bit of a filler
Arc um
yeah a b plot um uh mild well spoiler
spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler
spoiler but some people speculate that
this event might be a funeral uh for
spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler the uh
son of Allison Jaris who gets uh
cheesed it's aegon's
son oh sorry yes Aon and we've been live
for a long time don't yeah we're going
to wrap up this live stream shortly um
and I love that R is sort of like an
angelevil on Rene's shoulder here yeah I
mean I think more
Angel yeah she doesn't want the yeah but
like consider what she's done she's not
morally
unambiguous U and yeah we do know from
the books that the brackens and black
woods take this war as an opportunity to
do some fighting yeah um as happens all
over the country like a Dotan gry Joy
shows up yeah you know what there's a
wall going on let's do some reeving
there isn't really anything interesting
to say about this particular spoiler so
I don't think we need to you know yeah
true it's no fun spoil I don't like the
spoiler Zone yeah no I I don't get any
um I don't get this yeah because I know
what this is yeah we can just tell you
everything that's going to happen but
like that would not be fun for anyone if
you want to know everything that's going
to happen just read Fire and Blood or
read the world of Ice and Fire or read
the wiki I don't want to sit here and
tell you everything that's going to
happen seen in season three of Game of
Thrones where Joffrey tells you what
happens yeah if you want to know
everything that happens you can um
season 4 but I think we're going to I
think we're going to wrap it up there's
been a long live streamed thank you so
much everybody for listening this has
been fun hey thanks for having me on the
channel yeah you're very welcome to be
here this was fun uh and yeah maybe
we'll do some more streams again talk
about some more hot D next time there's
more Hot D to talk
about uh we will make Al shift x videos
about House of the Dragon when The
Season's on next time there's a trailer
out we'll probably make a video about
that uh for the time being I'm working
on the real Jon Snow video which is the
biggest Al shift x video ever and it's
all about Jon Snow uh in the books and
it's almost done and if you want to hear
about the fake Jon Snow head on over and
watch the season six
Bo oh boy yes well gladus has a bunch of
videos about the show and about Hot D
and what can we expect from you gladus
oh god well I'm just wrapping up my
house of the Dragon series hopefully
today um and then back to season six
with me hopefully I can finish that off
before House of the Dragon season 2 uh
starts airing maybe I can square raise
some other um ancient promises as well
oh I look forward to
it so do subscribe to glidus link in the
description do subscribe to alt shift x
uh you can listen to this live stream on
the the podcast stream on the alt giftex
podcast feed that's incredible so you
can listen to this on Spotify or the
podcast app of your
choice uh so yeah like And subscribe and
comment your favorite Dragon wig thank
you for the Super Chat from Canary and
we'll see you all next time
bye-bye
light